Yes.
Welcome back Dr Heart.
Good to see you brother.
Good to be here man.
Pull this sucker right up to you right there.
That's been good to be a,
I was in Mexico City and I'm in my hotel room and is only like two different
channels that speak English.
So while I'm forced to watch Fox News and I saw you on the bill O'Reilly show
those cluster fuck shows where they have one person like bill O'Reilly's the
host,
and then they have all these boxes with all these different people and
everybody's talking over everybody and the whole thing only lasts like three
minutes and they're tackling these complex subjects.
You got maybe like a half a sentence out before you got interrupted.
I don't even remember what the topic was.
It must've had something to do with drugs and addiction.
They brought you on,
right?
Yeah.
I think that episode was drugs and texting.
Addiction,
texting addiction.
Really?
That's what it was.
It,
it degenerated into texting addiction.
Yeah.
Jesus Christ.
Um,
I thought it was marijuana or something.
I'm not even,
it was marijuana initially.
Right.
Because we can concerned it about what they were concerned about.
The Hud does oppose it.
High number of marijuana users,
the new high number.
Right.
And then the thing is,
is that I was trying to make clear that the numbers of marijuana users today is
considerably lower than that.
What they were at 1978 or 1980 and but they weren't aware of the information
from 1978 or 1980 is that like the numbers per capita cause there's so many more
people now.
No.
Yeah,
it was percentage of,
in this case,
the percentage of high school students who were of marijuana use in the past 30
days or the past year.
Okay.
I've recently found out that there's a hundred million less Americans in 1970
than there are today.
Yeah,
that sounds about right.
Yeah.
It's fucking crazy.
If you really stop and think about that,
I mean 40 whatever years ago,
100 million less people.
Yeah,
yeah,
Yup.
We're still growing.
Yeah,
we're fucking crazy.
We can't keep this up.
That's ridiculous.
So there were,
there were smoking more pot back then.
More kids,
more per se.
A higher percentage.
You had a higher percentage of Americans who were smoking or using any illegal
drug was about 1978 and 1980 but at that time period,
it hasn't been anywhere near that high today.
It was probably like right after the Nixon administration,
like that fucking idiot probably had everybody just doing drugs.
When you got a president that's that messed up gets busted with Watergate and
you know,
all just all the foolishness and involved in his administration.
I bet he led people to drugs.
Well,
you know,
it does a whole lot of theories about it,
but you know,
one of the theories is that people became distrustful of government and things
that government was saying.
So not only that,
kids were experimenting in the 60s and it said,
and this was later in 70 [inaudible] they were still experimented and being
distrustful of the government.
So it's not surprising.
But the thing is is that even then drug use rates weren't that high really.
I mean,
because the people who were using marijuana at the time,
they're now running the country,
they're now doing the Derren,
these responsible positions and ended up doing about as well as previous
generations.
And so,
um,
uh,
it's not a big deal that people use drugs.
In fact,
you know,
I'm working on a new book and the thing is,
is that what I'm going to argue in the new book is that more people should be
using drugs.
Like what,
when you say more people should be using drugs.
Here's the thing about,
I hate the term I,
there's two terms that I have a real problem with it.
I don't,
I don't hate them,
but I think they're,
they're,
they're weighted addiction is one of them.
And drugs is another one.
Yeah,
because addiction is like when you start talking about addicting,
being addicted to texting,
I have friends that are definitely,
uh,
they definitely are inclined to check their phone way too much.
Like they feel compelled when they're in traffic,
they can feel like there's a red light and they're like,
oh good,
let me check my phone.
Like I'm at a red light,
like Jesus Christ,
what the fuck is going on?
But I think that's an impulse.
It's just a foolish pattern of thought to call that an addiction and then to
call like alcoholism,
the same thing where you could literally die if you stop drinking.
Well that's crazy.
This,
these are not the same things.
Yeah.
Well,
you know,
when we think about addiction,
it's a simple sort of definition that we use in medicine and the definition is
that,
does it cause you a tremendous amount of distress and is it disrupting your
social,
occupational,
your family sort of functioning that.
That's kind of it.
I mean,
so people can indulge in and behavior every day,
multiple times a day,
but they're handling their responsibilities and they are not distressed about
this behavior.
They wouldn't meet criteria for addiction.
Whereas somebody could like use alcohol or cocaine or some drug once a month or
once a week or what have you.
And then they have all of these disruptions surrounding that drug use and they
may meet criteria for addiction.
Whereas I could be using cocaine every day,
but handling my responsibilities,
it,
I'm not distressed by it.
Uh,
I don't have these problems are related to it.
I'm not an addict even though I'm using it every day.
So addiction has to do with social disruptions and being distressed,
not actual amount of youth or how many times you engage in the behavior.
But this sort of definition is missed upon many of people in,
in a general population.
Yeah.
Most people don't think about it that way.
Most people think that if you don't use it,
you're an like,
if you don't,
it will save you do something every day.
Like I had a friend who was a longshoreman and he worked with this guy that
would shoot heroin every day at lunch.
And that always freaked me out because the guy showed up for work everyday on
time.
He was a responsible guy,
he was married,
he had children and this guy would get heroin.
He would cop every morning.
He would go there and he would sit in his truck and he would shoot up and you
know,
whatever,
however long that that lasts,
you know,
he gets an hour lunch break and they would come back and go to work.
And I would like every day he goes,
every day.
I tried did it every day.
Well,
you know,
this past summer,
the past three months or so I was in Geneva,
just got back in the states.
Um,
and I was working in a heroin clinic where they administer heroin every day,
seven days a week,
twice a day to people who meet criteria for heroin addiction.
And when I say they administer heroin,
I don't mean like small doses,
I mean doses that they'll up to like a gram a day,
a thousand milligrams a day,
a lot more than what people use here in the states typically.
And these people who are getting heroin every day,
a large percentage of them also go to work.
A large percentage of them have families and they're taking care of their
responsibilities.
They are,
this is their treatment and this is a treatment that works for them.
But their treatment include two daily doses of intravenous heroin,
seven days a week,
you know,
and,
and so like when I think about,
well one of the reasons I went there,
and I did this because of the way we think of heroin in this country,
we think of it as such as evil drug.
And that's just a American mythology.
And,
and that's just wrong.
And that's ignorance and,
but that's how many including drug experts in this country think of heroin.
But
we have all of this great technology,
but we're so ignorant when it comes to many of these drugs.
So heroin administered intravenously on a daily basis is not,
it's not devastating.
No.
In fact,
some people would do better about having the daily doses,
a daily dose of heroin or another opiate.
Um,
no,
it's not devastating.
I didn't see even me.
I would go,
fuck man,
that's kind of fuck you up.
Like taking heroin every day.
Yeah.
And it's been this whole journey.
Men since I saw you last time,
I've been all over the world and this whole journey to see what people do with
drugs or with drugs they're using and how they do it.
It's been so eye opening even for me,
someone who has spent their life studying drugs and I'm learning so much more
now.
And,
but the Switz experience of,
uh,
the Dutch also do this.
There are some parts of Germany that does this.
They have small programs in the UK.
They had small program,
there are other countries,
but the Swiss by far have the biggest program and they've been the most
successful.
They've been doing this for more than 20 years now.
And they started doing this in response to,
um,
uh,
HIV concern.
People worried about folks getting HIV.
So they had to do something,
had to have clean needles,
we had to make sure that the drugs were pure.
Um,
so they're worried about death,
HIV,
all of those
things.
And this was the rational response where they put it in a medical community
where people got treatment and,
and,
um,
along with their heroin.
And they have no plans of going back,
nor should they because it works.
Boy,
that's hard for Americans to swallow.
Right.
And is it because of all the propaganda we've been fed?
Is it because just of misinformation?
I mean I would say propaganda,
but even me,
someone who's a pro drug,
for the most part person I would say God,
heroin every day he's probably going to fuck you up.
Yeah,
I mean,
but you,
you,
you raised a good question.
Is that part of the propaganda?
I don't know.
I mean obviously there are people who are using,
who used this as part of propaganda,
but in part but not,
I don't think they're trying to use it as pop.
Granted,
I think they're ignorant and they're close meaning people.
But then there are other people.
Just think about some of the films,
train spotting.
You think of a numb of these films.
All of those films now can't use that salacious story any more.
Death grip us.
It's not reality,
but it's,
it makes great films.
It may great sort of subjects with documentaries when we think about musical
heroes and people will say,
well,
they were misunderstood so they use heroin and they weren't.
That's not,
I mean they use heroin because it's a rational sort of a use of the drug.
When you think about its ability to decrease anxiety,
it's ability to like make people or have people relaxed and just be in a space
where they finally can get some peace.
When you think about all of the things that many of these sort of musical icons
are,
these great artists have to do with,
it's rational.
It makes rational sense.
The thing that I'm trying to do is how do we,
how do we allow people to do these things and be safe?
How do we still keep them say,
because people are going to do it.
That's a fact.
I mean,
we've been trying to get rid of heroin or in our country for sometimes,
but every year we have 100 or 200,000 new heroin users every year.
That number has not changed for 40 years.
Um,
and I don't expect it to change.
Well if that number hasn't changed,
but the population has increased,
you know,
how does that work?
Uh,
what,
that's why I was like between a hundred and 200,000 every year that,
I mean,
it's been,
it's been fluctuating between those numbers and,
but the point is that we're going to have a substantial proportion of heroin
users,
new new heroin users.
These are new heroin users every year.
And on top of that,
people don't consider the people that take opiates in pill form that are
prescribed by their doctors,
which is incredibly high.
And,
uh,
I've known many people,
I've,
I've close family members that have ruined their lives getting fucked up on
pills.
And I want to say addicted,
but now I'm,
I'm reluctant to say addicted,
but what,
maybe some word dicta.
I mean maybe that,
that,
that describes some people,
but,
but please understand the majority of people who use those pills using
responsibly
and they know what they're doing.
But there are people,
like you said,
who ruined their lives as a result.
But the the thing that we have to think about is that if the majority of users
of these pills are fine and then you have this subset to smaller subset who are
not,
it tells you that it's not the pills,
but by that same token,
there is still some issues I have with the way we have our pills or or the way
we do appeals in this country.
Opiate pills,
we put a seed of metaphysics in these pills and which I am not a fan of having
the seat of medicine in those fields because the seed of medicine,
it's the number one reason for liver toxicity and so sometimes if people really
want to push the dose of their opiate,
they have to get even more acetaminophen.
That would,
that's the more dangerous of the two and no situ in this situation.
Why did they put Acetaminophen in the pill?
What is the function of it?
It is stated that they put a seat of medicine in the pill because it's an added
pain reliever,
but I don't think that's the real reason.
I think the real reason that is in appeal is,
think of it this way.
Uh,
on the California highway,
I think the maximum speed limit is like 65 or 70.
Now imagine if someone designed,
so a car and let had tires on it that blew out when you reach 75 miles per hour.
So it's like the safety valve.
So you blow out the tires or somebody exceed the speed limit.
I think Acetaminophen is in the pills and opiate pills for that reason,
you take too much,
you blow out your liver,
you die really.
So you think they put it in there for added liver toxicity to make sure people
don't take too much of the opiates,
I think is in there.
Yeah.
To discourage the use of opiates.
Absolutely.
Wow.
And I think that,
and I think that's sick and I think that that's a problem because when you think
about even other countries like Geneva or Switzerland,
you don't see a seed of metaphor.
And in these medications like they are here,
you certainly don't have people prescribing them like they do here with the
Acetaminophen.
Eh,
you know,
it's like you don't need that in there.
If you want somebody to take an additional pain reliever,
you prescribe it or you tell him you recommend it,
but you don't need,
uh,
the number one reason for liver toxicity in a,
with opiates I think is there to have people blow out their livers or do to
discourage people from taking more opiates.
So would that be to alleviate their responsibility too,
to make sure that less people have opiate addictions?
Like what,
why I,
that doesn't make any sense to me.
Yeah.
So it's like,
okay,
if you know that you,
if you,
if you take too much acetaminophen and that would discourage you from taking
the,
the opiate.
That's what I think the reason.
Wow.
That seems weird to me.
That seems like they would have had to,
I've had a paper trail in order to,
uh,
I mean it seems like that that has to be something that would be discussed.
Well,
I think,
like I said,
the,
the stated reason is that it provides an additional pain reliever.
And I'm saying it doesn't make any sense.
If you want to have that additional pain reliever,
simply give somebody a seed,
a metaphor or Ibuprofen or something else,
but you don't need to put it in with what Ryan would each other.
Yeah.
So would they do that to make some sort of a proprietary blend or something like
that where their pills would be different than others?
Does that make any sense?
No.
Nope.
Because these things are all generic now,
right there.
So there's no one making tons of money at the result of this.
They're all generic and they all have that stuff in them.
In the United States.
You think about,
you've heard of Vicodin,
if I could add is I think a oxycodone and a seed,
a metaphysics Percocet perks that actually is oxycodone,
uh,
biking in,
it's hydrocodone and Acetaminophen,
but all of these Percodan,
Percocet,
Percodan,
Vicodin,
all of these things have acetaminophen in it.
Wow.
You know,
I don't have a lot of experience with,
uh,
opiates,
but I did get a knee surgery once and they gave me this morphine trip.
They gave me this little thing that you could press anytime you want
that didn't have a seat of benefit.
I pressed the shit out of that button,
but that did not have that,
did not,
that did not,
that didn't have a seat,
have a better fit.
And then do you,
like you said,
you press that button and then you probably needed it and that's cool.
That and you were successful.
You're doing your thing,
you have a successful podcast.
I mean that's luckily,
I dunno man,
if you kept the,
kept me with that button might be still on that hospital.
But
you know,
that's,
I'm just fucking around.
But I do have a friend that broke,
no knows my friend Brendan shop,
he broke his nose and they put them on those pills.
They put them on a oxycontin's,
um,
after the game.
Uh,
no surgery.
And uh,
his friends wound up taking them away from him after a couple of months.
He was just taking them all day.
It could,
it certainly could have,
like I said,
been there are some people get in trouble,
but the mass majority of people don't.
But the problem is that people,
they,
they're simple reframe is that it's these pills,
these pills.
So you,
you think that
some people just have that sort of compulsive behavior and that behavior could
manifest itself in drink it too much coffee or it could manifest itself and
taking those pills or it's essentially the behavior that's an issue more than it
is the actual substance or the medicine.
Well,
you know,
people overindulge in activities for a variety of reasons.
And if we really want to understand why they do it,
we have to understand that individual person's situation.
Right.
And oftentimes we're too damn lazy to do that.
And then it's so much easier just to blame the drug.
But when we blame the drug,
there are some serious consequences.
And that's what I'm saying,
it's like the consequences.
It's that now we have this new legislation,
we have this new effort go at the people
who use these drugs.
And that consequence though,
those consequences are inappropriate.
And so that's why I try and get people to just be like,
well look at the individual person's situation.
What happened with that person?
Cause it ain't the drug.
I assure you that that's,
it's fascinating that in Switzerland they're doing that.
Gin Is Geneva.
That's where he said it was.
Well Geneva,
Zurich burn.
Um,
yeah.
Throughout the major cities in Switzerland
and they're giving them these high doses.
Do they have a program if they want to wean off,
if these people want to stop doing it?
Yeah.
So this program is for
people who want to stop people who want to continue.
They also have methadone,
they have buprenorphine,
they have other soda treatments as well.
But they just,
this is just one of many options.
That's all.
And the Methadone is what we always heard of in America.
Like the,
I think I told this story last time you were here,
but I used to play pool at this place that was right next to a methadone clinic.
And these people that would go on,
they'd get their methadone and then they'd come over and play pool and they just
look like zombies.
We'd call them Methadone,
Ian's,
that's who he used to call them.
But they would come over,
just zoned out and they would just fucking out of it.
And this guy that I worked with was saying,
um,
he was like,
you know that Methadone Shit they give them is actually worse than the heroin?
And I was like,
that doesn't make any sense.
Why wouldn't they just give them heroin?
Well,
I mean that's,
that's the question that the Swiss ass,
why don't you just give people what they want?
Right.
I mean,
so there are re their,
their answers to that question.
I mean,
you,
you said Methadone was probably worth it certainly can be for some people
because the half life of Methadone is a lot longer.
It lasts forever.
It stays in your blood for a long time compared to heroin.
So some people say,
well,
you know,
I don't want to have a long acting opiate such that it makes me feel kind of
slow.
That's why I want to use heroin as opposed to methadone.
Whereas other people,
Methadone worked for it.
That's fine.
Whatever works.
Um,
eh,
but then there are people who said what,
just give folks what they want.
And that's what the Swiss say in,
in this case,
what heroin.
There'll be some heroin users who say,
I want to get off of heroin.
I want to do whatever I can do to get off because I don't want to shoot a
needle,
for example,
and Methadone works well for them.
Buprenorphine works well for them,
but then there are other people who just say,
no,
I want to continue to use heroin with the needle,
and as an adult you should have that.
Right?
You should have that option.
Yeah.
That is the issue,
right?
Isn't it?
Because if we can freely purchase alcohol,
and even more insidious in a way is the amount of sugar consumption that people
in this country,
especially our consumption of sugar,
and this is something I've really been focusing on a lot lately because I've
been educating my kids about how much sugar is in things.
It's really hilarious because my seven year old was talking to my five year
yesterday and she's
like,
there's nine grams of sugar in that.
They're having this little conversation about this thing that she wants to drink
that's supposed to be healthy.
She's like reading it,
there's nine grams to see a seven year old do that.
I'm like,
wow,
this is kinda cool.
Um,
but sugar can fuck people's lives up for sure.
And I know a lot of people that are addicted to sugar,
not just compelled to eat it,
but it actually changes their gut flora.
You know,
the actual,
uh,
the floor inside their body craves this to the point where these people,
it gets,
they get crazy for it.
People get really crazy for sugar and it's just causes all sorts of health
consequences.
But no one wants to say,
Hey,
we should outlaw candy bars.
No one should say that.
Right,
exactly.
Right.
Same thing.
It was booze,
right?
No,
no.
We have Ge.
We could,
we all,
everyone in this room,
we could drink ourselves to death just with the shit that I have in my closet
over here and that little kitchen,
we could go in there and just chug those bottles and we'd all be dead.
They'd find a salt dead.
That's crazy right now.
But we won't do it.
Right.
Exactly.
I mean,
we just drove a car here.
I could have just driven that car off of a cliff.
Yeah.
But we don't do that because we are adults and we are,
you know,
we have some autonomy.
The same should be true with sugar.
The same should be true with these drugs.
But the thing is,
it's that one of the things that concerns us about sugar is that for so long
we've been lied to about the role of sugar in disease,
uh,
men.
So people didn't realize that sugar was causing all of these problems.
And so people felt like they were misled.
That's okay.
Now we have better education.
So now you make these decisions with your eyes open.
The same could be done with drugs.
You make these decisions with your eyes open.
You're an adult.
You certainly can get in trouble with this particular drug or that particular
drug.
But here's how you do it more safely.
You certainly can get in trouble with sugar,
but here's how you can do it in a way that's reasonable and more safe than not.
And through education instead of by demonizing things and by propaganda.
And I think,
uh,
being more lipstick,
that's,
you know,
it's,
we are very judgmental and more realistic about a number of things.
And I think that the drug issue is ideal for a perpetuating our moralism.
Mm.
Yeah.
That's,
it's,
and it's a weird one too,
right?
Because don't you drink wine in church?
We serve wine.
That's fucking [inaudible] been to church in a while either,
but I'm pretty sure,
I'm pretty sure that it's the supposed to signify the blood of Christ.
Right?
Is that it?
Yeah,
it's booze.
They're getting hoot hoot stuff,
which to for Jesus.
But it's,
um,
w w would just,
we're,
we're very strange in what we allow and don't allow other adult human beings to
do.
And that,
uh,
that really sort of gets to the heart of all this.
And then we're also very squeamish about the idea of needles.
And when you say this program in Geneva,
super successful,
and the giving people intravenous heroin up to thousand milligrams a day,
I'm like,
wow.
Needles,
Jesus.
You know,
that's,
that's something the,
the actual administration of it,
like the method of administration makes people squeamish.
Yeah.
You know,
but we give needles in hospitals.
We do those sorts of things and eliminate things about this program.
That's nice is that they have clean needles,
they have clean drug and so it decreases the likelihood that day we have
abscesses.
It's,
and those sorts of things or other sorts of blood born illnesses or concerns,
they are decreased.
In fact,
people are more healthy being in these programs.
Obviously the not being in these programs.
Um,
so,
uh,
they,
they have made me,
they've convinced me.
So intravenous heroin can in effect w act in a lot of the ways that maybe some
prescription drugs like Xanax or maybe some antidepressants do where they
alleviate the anxiety that certain people have.
Oh yeah.
I mean the heroin soda or,
so a number of these people have to tell you they have psychiatric illnesses.
It's like some of them have schizophrenia,
some of them have depression.
They have a wide range of illness.
It's just like any other,
um,
identified addicted population.
Heroin for example,
helps people in,
in many cases control.
They're sort of psychotic behaviors.
They are sort of delusions.
Um,
and so heroin can be a very useful drug in a wide range of soda for price range
of symptoms.
We know this,
uh,
as we,
as people in medicine notice,
well let me clarify,
at least people in medicine outside of the United States now this,
this isn't,
this is not anything that's earth shattering or groundbreaking.
Well what is the difference between the education that they receive outside of
the United States and inside of the United States?
Just the bias that we have about certain medicines.
Yeah,
we are,
we cannot divorce,
um,
our drug education from our social control.
And so when we think about how drugs or drug policy has been used to go at the
groups that we don't like,
and if we're not a part of the outgroup,
we just kind of accept this information uncritically.
And we've been told that people who use heroin,
they have those issues and they're not like us.
They are those people.
And why is,
why should we question it?
We don't know them very well and we see people putting a needle in their arm.
Something must be wrong with them.
And so you can tell all of these incredible stories.
Physicians believe these stories in this country,
uh,
our medical experts or addiction experts believe this sort of stuff.
But it's not true.
It's not reality.
Um,
and so that's one of the reasons that I traveled and not continue to travel and
to learn.
And I'm learning so much about the thing that my bias sees that I held and that
I'm trying to get rid of.
I'm trying
to really just focus on the evidence.
So in a sense like the United States is very unique in its,
in its propaganda and then unique and it's sort of singular view on drugs.
Well,
given that we have such a big military,
it's hard for us to be unique because other countries,
what our military might and our money,
we kind of tell them what the thing too.
So we're not unique.
Canada,
Canada's won,
but all of South America or large portion of South America,
even some places in Europe,
Asia,
you know a number of places share our screwed up views on drugs because they've
been told to share out screwed up views because they get some money for having
these screwed up views.
Like we support various programs in Columbia about drugs.
A eradication of drugs end up all around the world.
So these countries share our views.
But places like Geneva,
that's really autonomy's and there are some other autonomous nations that
actually look at the evidence and see what's best for their population and that
was best for the people at the United States.
And,
and,
and they don't just accept the propaganda without thinking about their
population.
Have you seen there's a new TV show?
Fear the walking dead.
It's like the,
the new spin off that's in La.
I had no,
I mean I've been away from the United States,
so I watched it and I thought immediately of you because there's a character in
it that is a heroin addict.
This young son is a heroin addict.
And a while he was in this,
spoiler alert everybody,
if you're a fan of the show and you haven't watched any of the,
I dunno,
spoiler alert here comes fast forward.
Um,
the kids a a junkie and he's in this,
this drug den and he's shooting up and this chick,
he's friends with turns into a Zombie.
He starts eating people's faces and shit.
And I was like so much of water.
Yeah,
that's great stuff.
Well,
they get him to a whole the get them to a hospital,
right?
He,
uh,
they've got the hospital for days,
right?
He's a little sick at first and then he seems fine.
And then his,
uh,
his withdrawals kickin and his cravings kick in.
I'm like fucking days later,
like days later he can't take it anymore.
He's shaking and he's throwing up all over himself and he falls to the ground.
He has seizures and throws up on himself.
But if like a day ago the kid was fine a day ago,
like his face has all the color in it who looks normal.
And I remember what you had said last time you were here.
That withdrawal is a lot like getting the flu.
It's like getting sick and then it goes away and everything else is just sort of
in your head.
Well,
yeah,
you know,
the severity can,
can,
can vary based on the extent that a lot of people been using the drug obviously.
But yeah,
it's the flu basically.
And um,
you're not going to die.
And all of the sort of dramatic characterizations that we see on TV,
it's the sell their,
it's really
to sell their product.
And the problem is,
is that people get educated on that,
bullish on that sort of stuff,
right?
Yeah.
You were gonna say bullshit.
What's the right way to say it?
Oh yeah,
it is bullshit.
Forgot where am I thought I was
Riley.
My best
if want Riley,
you would've been interrupted 150 times already.
We've already gotten to 30 commercials.
Yeah.
This,
uh,
this kid in the show,
he's mother actually breaks it.
Spoiler alert,
spoiler alert.
His mother actually breaks into the school to get pills for him.
Yeah.
She breaks back into school and she has to fight zombies and shit,
but she breaks into the school to get pills for her son and she's going to like
slowly wean him off with these pills.
But the fucking kid was normal just a day ago,
you know?
Yeah.
You know,
my,
it's too hard for me to watch the stuff.
I mean,
you know,
on the one hand it's like I'm trying to be a regular citizen and just,
appreciate art or what people do.
But then on the other hand,
it's just that I just know the consequences of that rubbish,
you know,
and the consequences that it gives some idiotic politician a raison d'etre.
So he,
they feel like this is their reason for being now and then they can go after
this drug because they saw it on his awful TV show.
TV shows actually really good.
Yeah.
Well
I think the real issue is,
um,
like many people,
the writers and the producers probably aren't heroin users.
So their idea is based on the popular mythology,
the popular culture,
the idea that we've all been sort of fed by train spotting.
And all these other films.
There's sort of just repeating that.
No,
I'm glad you pointed out that you can have a good TV show,
but get the drug issue wrong and that,
that's a great point.
Yeah.
Was his real wrong obviously,
but a lot of us have this idea and like,
I swear before I met you,
I mean,
and I'm a person who's,
I'm not averse to drugs.
I thought of it all as I thought heroin.
Like,
Oh yeah,
man,
you can get addicted.
You do it once you're addicted and then you're fucked.
It's just somehow or another becomes a part of you.
That's why I've always had a problem when they start talking about marijuana
addiction,
like how many people get addicted to marijuana because I don't understand what
even the mechanism would be for you to get addicted to that.
Yeah,
I mean,
uh,
again,
if we go back to the definition that I talked to the start,
yeah.
When we think about social disruption,
disruption of family function,
work and that sort of thing,
and it's causing you distress.
You can clearly see how somebody might be addicted to marijuana,
a low percentage of people become addicted to marijuana,
but you certainly can see that.
Yeah,
somebody might get distressed by their marijuana use,
fine,
and so they can meet criteria for addiction,
but when you compare marijuana addiction to alcohol,
nicotine,
cocaine,
or any other drug,
it's lower than all the rest of those drug.
But certainly
it's possible that somebody has some distress and hab,
psychosocial disruptions and functioning.
So the disruptions and functioning is what really identify someone as being an
addict.
But if someone is a person who is using heroin on a daily basis but shows no
disruption in their life shows no problems with their,
their social situation or their job functioning or anything like that,
but then they get off of it.
Yeah.
Then they're an addict because if they get off of it or they try to quit cold
Turkey and then they get all fucked up because of that,
well then you would have to kind of qualify them or,
well it,
that's just one criteria.
Withdrawal symptoms of only one criteria and you have to have,
I mean that's something,
one symptom.
So you have to have several symptoms,
right?
In order to meet criteria for addiction.
But if you only have withdrawal,
that's not an addict.
I mean,
cause you can think about somebody who's taking an antidepressant medication or
somebody who's taken more freeing for pray.
All those people can experience withdrawal,
but we wouldn't call them an addict.
I mean it's just like withdrawal.
It's just the common sort of drug effect at the longterm.
Use Arbitrage,
caffeine,
withdrawal,
all of these things are,
I mean,
when people have a hangover,
oftentimes that that's acute withdrawal.
That's just an acute sort of manifestation of withdrawal center.
But we wouldn't call them an alcoholic simply because they went out and partied
for a couple of nights.
And so withdrawal is not the,
not the only criteria that we use to determine addiction,
but most people would and most people would be wrong.
And that's part of the problem here.
Right?
Cause they,
they,
they are looking only yet withdraw,
which what's your all is it's not a big deal.
Uh,
and well it's the only,
it only becomes a big deal when we're talking about alcohol withdraw from
chronic alcohol use or we're talking about barbiturate withdrawal from chronic
use because the person can die outside of those drugs.
I mean those are the only sort of more commonly used drugs that we worry about.
Withdrawal,
the rest it there you'll be fine.
People constantly throw around the term addiction then I guess in an incorrect
way.
And it technically incorrect way because um,
I know a lot of people that I would say are addicted to coffee where they need
to have coffee in order to wake up and function.
Yeah.
But like you said that they,
they use it wrong.
Yeah.
So maybe because the coffee is actually helping them to maybe do their job
better and not disrupting their job.
The coffee is even is helping them in their human function.
Well,
the last time you were here you explained something that really,
I never knew either.
It's that the,
the thing you just discussed that withdrawal is actually,
or rather a hangover is actually your body withdrawing like the compensatory
mechanisms that your body uses to deal with the alcohol in your system.
That's what the feeling of being hung over is.
Is your body just withdrawing from that alcohol?
Certainly that that certainly that can be a symptom of withdrawal.
The hangover,
absolutely.
I mean you,
you put a foreign substance into your body and your body tries to adjust,
try to,
we call it homeostasis.
This is a normal response and then alcohol is half.
Life is so short that it's in the body and then before your body gets a chance
to just completely,
it's gone,
but your body has already overcompensated and so what you're seeing is this
expression in some cases,
how difficult is this?
Like when you,
when you,
if you tried to discuss this to like the bill Reilly crowd like that there's a
lot of people that are not going to swallow this definition.
Like their idea of deficit there.
Their definition of addiction is very different than what you're saying.
You know,
like before,
before we went on air,
you and I was talking a little bit this past summer,
I've been all over.
I mean just past,
well since I saw you last,
I've been every,
I've been all over the globe.
And one of the things that when I give these talks and when people say,
I heard you on the Joe Rogan show,
you know,
all over the world from Vancouver to Brazil to Geneva,
to the Philippines all over.
Um,
I know when they say that I heard you on the Joe Rogan show,
I know that they are thinking people.
I know that these are people who,
um,
look for information outside of the normal sort of source of information.
And so those are the people who I'm trying to reach,
the people who are actually grappling and struggling with these ideas and trying
to evaluate the ideas for the merits based on their merits.
And that's it.
Whereas when you talk about the O'Reilly's and you talk about the politicians
and you talk about these people,
those are the people who I like talking to lease.
I mean,
not necessarily a O'Reilly himself,
but some of the people who watch him.
Um,
uh,
and so I'm trying to reach the general public,
the people who come,
who watch your shelter,
people who were into what you do,
the common folk who are out there,
which,
who are struggling and they're trying to learn.
And I think if we reached them,
the politicians will follow them,
not the opposite way around.
And so my least favorite people to talk to our politicians,
I mean,
it's as an adult,
me and you,
we,
you'd like to talk to people who take you seriously,
particularly when you're respecting them.
Politicians oftentimes don't give a shit about you.
They only care about their votes and how they can use you for those votes.
You know,
it's insulting to me to talk to people in that way.
And so I,
I try to avoid them coming here to this place.
I know that there'll be people out here who listened to you who was struggled
with this and,
but they'll,
we'll evaluate it based on its merits.
And that's all you can ask is that people evaluate your arguments based on the
merits and then you have
conversations,
discussions,
and you go back and forth and you the best evidence win and everybody
understands those rules.
And those are your listeners.
That's not the politicians,
that's not the talk show host.
Those are not those people.
And so they're,
they're not the people who I'm trying to reach and,
and,
and it helps to keep me sane because I can't deal with people who don't use
evidence or don't play what evidence.
It's part of the rules.
Yeah,
that's a great quote.
That's on your website about a,
I made sure that I don't engage in conversations with people that don't abide by
the rules of evidence.
That's a great quote.
And I agree with you about politicians too,
because essentially politicians just go where the wind of public opinion goes.
And so many of them,
they have a team of people deciding what they're talking about.
The team of idiots.
Oftentimes,
yes.
And uh,
unfortunately those people,
oftentimes they'll,
when these politicians,
they'll get involved in debates,
are get involved in some sort of a public function where they're discussing
something or giving a speech and they can say things that are just absolutely
inaccurate.
And those things,
when people aren't really discerning or they don't have the time maybe to go
over the evidence,
these people take that as fact.
Yeah,
no,
you know,
this is why I continue to be out here.
Because when people make those kinds of statements based on no evidence and
they're just lies,
it's just inaccurate.
The consequences of those lies and the accuracies are so great and there are so
many poor people who paid a price for it.
That's why I continue to stay out here and I stay out here to call those people
out on it and try to embarrass those people.
I mean,
I'm a,
I'm a firm believer in embarrassing politicians when they tell these lies,
when they make up this information because they are ruining too many people's
lives.
As a result,
we will,
they're agents of poor information oftentimes whether they want to be or not.
I think all they want to do is get elected and stay in power and,
and then serve whoever paid for their campaign.
That's it.
That's exactly it.
It's a terrible system.
If you think about it that way.
That's it.
That's,
it's a terrible system.
That's why I'm glad you do your thing and I'm glad that people all around the
world are checking you out.
Well,
now when you're on these travels and you're,
you're going around the world,
did you go to Portugal at all?
Did you talk to anybody from there?
I talked to people.
They're like high officials there,
but I haven't been to Portugal yet.
And you know,
I think you bring up Portugal because they decriminalized all drugs.
Um,
so two digit Czech Republic,
Czech Republic did it before Portugal,
but we all know about Portugal.
Um,
and uh,
so that's a good thing.
I mean,
it's just simply means that people can't be arrested for drug possessions and,
and a drug possession is considered like a 10 day supply of drugs in Portugal,
which is a good thing.
And then there are other places
around the world that people are doing other innovative things.
Like in Sao Paulo,
Brazil,
the mayor of Mira,
who dodge is,
I'm paying drug addicts or drug users,
paying them a salary,
giving them housing,
um,
uh,
giving them food,
three meals and that sort of thing to make sure they show up for work and they,
and then if they're coming to work,
that means they're not getting into other activities.
And so he's trying to keep his certain areas of his city safe doing that.
Um,
and then we talked about the Swiss and we,
and so there are a number of people thinking about innovative ways to deal with
drugs and to treat people like adults and not children.
Like in our country,
we just still concerned about moralism even though there had been some states to
have said,
as you well know,
Colorado,
Alaska,
Oregon,
Washington,
they've said that we're going to legalize marijuana for adults and they have,
and I suspect California will vote and um,
uh,
November 16 to see if they want,
if they want to do the same thing.
So despite the sort of a moralism,
we still have some people,
uh,
out here pushing for progressive,
rational adult sort of drug laws.
And so I,
I hope we continue to see this.
When I look at the current state of politics in America and I look at,
um,
what we call our leaders and the way they discuss drugs.
What I'm looking at is it's almost like they're trapped in an ancient way of
thinking that doesn't work anymore because of the Internet,
because of the Internet where we have so much access to information now we have,
we have,
we have a freedom to actually find the truth.
So like what you're talking about where people have these misconceptions and
then you come on and you give the absolute truth.
Fact based evidence and you're forced to like examine.
Like why do I have these assumptions in my head?
Why do I have and why,
why do why?
I mean,
I,
I was forced to confront these when I talked to the first time,
I was like,
why do I have these ideas in my head that I have I really researched them?
Is this something that I've my out there in the field talking to people that are
addicts talking to people that are treating them?
Absolutely not.
No,
this is just trainspotting.
This is just,
you know,
popular culture politics,
given politicians giving speeches that that's all I know of it.
And I think the,
our,
our base of understanding is expanding.
I agree.
I mean,
these people like you.
Well,
thank you.
I mean,
because of what you're doing,
obviously these alternative media forms,
right?
I mean,
when I think about coming to your show,
um,
my publicist and those people,
they wasn't on the book ray radar,
which is a mistake.
But I mean,
we know better now.
People are,
are learning now.
So that's really encouraging to me that we have these forms of media out here
on,
on the one hand.
Um,
but you,
you made,
you made a point,
um,
uh,
it's,
it's slipped my mind now.
We can,
we can go on.
I forgot to,
um,
well about politics being stuck in,
Oh yeah.
So as we think about the politician as we think about the politician,
I think the last Republican debate,
there were a couple of politicians,
I think Jay Bush and Christie and they were saying how they would bring the
federal government in to change what's going on in Colorado.
Chris Christie Guy.
Yeah,
yeah.
Those guys.
And they,
they,
you know,
that kind of logic and thinking.
Um,
I think that if he actually got the nomination,
that wouldn't happen.
I don't know if they have to say these kinds of things,
but it would be nice if the American people really punished these idiot to say
things like that.
Because on the one hand,
we think about the folks at Colorado taking this vote and the whole issue of
states' rights and this is what the Republicans say they really like.
Well,
I don't mean to go out to Republicans or cause I think they're the same as
Democrats quite frankly.
Uh,
so it's not,
that's is not,
this is not a knock on them as a party.
Uh,
but when people talk about,
uh,
a state's right,
right.
That's what this is it the state have decided.
And so the public,
the American people should really slam idiots who say things like they're going
to go out there,
stay.
What about this issue of states'?
Right.
I mean,
and,
and so I think Republicans and Democrats,
she really go out to these people for saying remarks like that.
Well,
Chris Christie in particular,
because a lot of the things that he says are totally inaccurate.
And then on top of it,
what is his concern?
I'm assuming his concern is the health consequences of marijuana use.
Well,
the health consequences of being a gigantic fat fuck are way worse than the
health consequences of marijuana use.
I mean,
that guy is morbidly obese and he's talking about people who smoke a plant that
makes them happy.
That's ridiculous.
The idea that you're going to take that right away from responsible adults like
me.
Like I'm,
I don't know how old he is,
but I don't think he's much older than enough either.
Yeah,
no,
I hear you.
I love you.
Outrage about this.
I mean,
but this is how this is what Americans have to do about heroin,
about cocaine.
Uh,
boy,
that's a tough sell man.
That's why I said it.
It's a tough sell.
But people think of coke is due to,
won't shut the fuck up at parties.
I want to start businesses with you.
Want to tell you about some shit that they never really did.
That's what people think about coke assholes where they know they haven't had
done coke where people had no damn,
I need to be around at least people you know that do coke cause everybody I've
been around that on coke is an idiot.
Well you know some of the people who do cocoa around me or in government,
so I guess they can pass as it is to.
So same thing with um,
alcohol,
right?
I mean,
here's a,
here's an example.
There was a,
a guy that I know that a soldier that,
uh,
came back from Afghanistan,
he's got all sorts of pain issues from the war and he takes,
uh,
oxycontin and he is trying to get off of it.
He slowly weaning himself out,
but he'll take like a couple of day every day.
And uh,
he was describing it to me when I was at a bar and my immediate reaction is
like,
wow,
man,
that dude's on it right now.
He seems so normal.
Like,
and then while I'm thinking that I'm next to people that are drunk off their ass
at this fucking bar,
at the Improv,
I mean,
these people are hammered,
just sloshed and they're probably doing way more damage to their body right
there.
And I'm like,
wow,
there's poor flux on pills.
You know?
I mean,
it's,
it's interesting how we have these categorizations that like the pill,
the Oxycontin pill,
like,
oh,
this guy's,
he's gotta be fucked up.
Meanwhile,
to my left,
there's a bar filled with people just throwing back this liquid poison and
torture in their liver and their brain.
Yeah,
man.
See this is the new book,
man,
when it comes out,
I'm going to have to come here.
But this is precisely what I'm trying to deal with it.
I'm trying to show people how to use drugs to enhance human functioning
experience and so forth.
Now that means that as we get older,
we may have to change out drug use from some like alcohol,
alcohol might be a little too toxic on some of our liberties as we get older,
toxic in other ways for us as we get older.
And some other drugs like oxycontin or something else might be more beneficial
for you to achieve that goal that you're trying to achieve.
And that's what the new book is trying to,
trying to look at to help people change their drug use according to their age,
their maturity,
all of these things and how to keep them safe and also to help them to
accomplish that goal that they seek to enhance human experiences.
When we go to parties,
we take drugs.
Um,
we take alcohol and noted to as a social lubricant,
you know,
but maybe that social lubricant isn't working for me as much these days.
Alcohol disrupts my sleep,
you know,
whereas an opiate,
it's perfect.
You know,
I can chill,
I can relax and I can get some great sleep and I can be here,
uh,
to do your show and be bright and bushy tailed and I'm ready to go as opposed to
having that dream the night before but have an oxycontin or something else.
That's interesting.
You know,
I think also we're dealing with a,
a reaction like when,
when you were talking about,
uh,
people in the 1970s that were doing,
the higher percentage of them were smoking marijuana and it could have been a
reaction to the Nixon administration.
I think in a situation like that,
you,
you get preacher's daughter
sort of affect the suppression where people just want to react to that
suppression.
People don't like being told what to do.
And in,
in the case of things like cocaine,
there's that naughty factor.
There's the fact that it's forbidden.
Does this factor that what you're doing is something that's illegal and that
makes it more exciting?
I think that's one of the things that was highlighted by the decriminalization
in Portugal and the subsequent effects when the and any,
even Colorado,
when you look at the cow,
what what they've shown in Colorado is the lowest instances of drunk driving and
I think something like 15 years low instance of violent crime that they've had
in a long time and no deaths,
you know,
they're talking about like one guy jumped off of a building when he was high on
pot.
Edibles.
Listen,
people make shitty choices all the time,
whether on pot edibles or they drink too much dr pepper or they have too many
fucking Twinkies.
I mean,
wasn't there a guy in San Francisco that killed somebody that used Twinkies as
a,
a defense?
The twinkie defense?
Yeah.
It was like a famous defense because sugar is a drug.
I think that we're responsible adults being able to make choices based on
evidence and based on on reality.
In fact,
that should be the foundation of our society.
How we treat almost everything.
Joe,
man,
you,
you just laid it out with marijuana.
I absolutely agree with you,
but I just,
I want to push you to think about heroin in the same way.
Cocaine about same way because what you just said about marijuana,
you're absolutely right,
but it also applies to these other psychoactive trucks.
Um,
we just need to make sure people know how to do these things safely.
I,
I'm,
I'm opening my mind to this.
I just don't have any experience in any of those.
I was always scared of a coke because when I grew up,
I had a,
a friend and his cousin got,
he became a mess.
He was selling it and all this dude dude was a Duke coke and hang out in his
house and watch TV and sell coke and he lost a ton of weight and he looked like
shit.
And it's just like he made some bad choices,
but he could have made those bad choices doing a lot of different things.
Just like you talked about,
the guy who possibly drunk jumped out of the building at the edibles and it had
some other issues.
You're absolutely right.
There are a lot of issues.
I mean,
you can,
I'm sure,
I mean,
you can look at my talks,
you can look at other people.
You can see,
you'd be like,
okay,
can you tell what drug I'm on?
Can you tell what drug this person is on King?
Of course you can't.
Right.
Um,
uh,
because people are,
most of us are adults and responsible and know what we're doing.
What's a good drug to take right before you do the O'Reilly's show?
Oh,
sh uh,
um,
no,
actually what the O'Reilly walkers,
a Beta blocker might be helpful.
Uh,
but you want to just take a low
dose of amphetamine so you can be really alert and attentive and ready to go.
Yeah.
You'd be ready to go.
That's that style.
You know,
I had a Peter Shift,
you know,
he is,
he's a,
um,
he's a financial genius and I'm very controversial character.
Very,
very,
very successful but has these like controversial ideas about economics.
But I had him on the podcast and a,
I don't know how many podcasts he's done,
but he started off the show like,
cause that's how they do it.
You know when you go on those talk shows,
you gotta be able to fucking fire Dah Dah,
Dah,
Dah.
But this shows three hours of just chilling out and talking.
So about an hour and a half in,
he starts to slow down.
I'm like,
you want a drink?
I was like,
yeah,
I'll have a drink.
So we got him a Jack Daniels on the rocks,
we sit and then,
and then he got casual about an hour and a half in and it became an actual
conversation.
Like I'm,
I know virtually nothing about finances.
So I wasn't challenging.
Am I just asking questions and I wanted to find out,
you know,
I wanted to get him to aluminate certain perspectives,
but he was ready for someone to jump in.
He was ready to beat that split screen thing.
When you have one person on one side,
one of the other,
and they have opposing viewpoints and they just talking over each other.
I understand.
I sympathize with the cat cause I,
you know how it is and then before you know it,
it's over and then you don't really get many of us think to,
all right,
it's our opportunity to educate the American public.
It's not,
it's really an opportunity for the host to show how smart they are.
There's a lot of them.
Yeah,
it's all,
it's just also a lot of just preaching to the choir nonsense and they want the
conflict of two people with opposing viewpoints yelling at each other and
calling each other morons and pseudo symmetry is what they want.
To pretend that each issue has in a certain amount of evidence over here and a
certain amount of evidence over here and the,
and the,
and the sort of real story somewhere in the middle.
No,
most issues don't happen like that,
but that's how nonthinking people can see the world.
But the world doesn't work like that.
No,
it doesn't.
What was that documentary?
Jamie,
do you remember the name of the documentary that I was talking about where
there's just people that were hired to go on and talk about,
uh,
Jesus Christ.
I just washed it really recently.
What does it Mirage man?
Was it mirage madness?
Yeah.
Um,
they were hired to go on the shows and talk about whether it was initially it
was whether or not cigarettes and nicotine were bad for your health and
addictive.
And then it became about global warming,
the same people.
And they would go on all these different talk shows and just spout out this
stuff very loudly and with confidence.
And that was literally their job.
They were being hired to do this.
So they'd go on these talk shows and they would just,
Yap.
They would just,
just talk real loud and real confidently and talk over people and their,
their,
their function or their,
their career was to try to change opinion with these short little bursts.
Yeah.
Yup.
That's what they do.
And I don't do that very well.
Yeah.
Well,
that's why I had to contact you after I saw you on O'Reilly.
I was like,
you look so frustrated because that shows it's so fucking retarded.
You know,
I try not to show frustration.
I really do.
So if I did,
that's not,
that's not good.
Well I should say knowing you,
you looked mildly perturbed on the outside.
Like if I didn't know you,
I'd be like,
well that got handled that really well cause they just fucking talked over him.
I mean they give you like,
I mean,
I'm,
I'm not even exaggerating.
You might've had to talk for,
you might've got out 20 seconds worth of talking before they were talking over
you.
Yeah.
You know,
um,
the thing,
it's just so perplexing to me that you can be so irresponsible and have this
stuff be on the airwaves and not get in trouble for it.
And then what they are doing on many of these shows,
they're doing more harm to the American education then more the most people.
And yet they're not in jail.
In fact,
they're being rewarded handsomely for this sort of day.
And then we're putting people in jail for these other minor infraction.
It's the stored it man.
It's something really sick about this system.
It is.
And it seems like it's trapped in momentum that these,
these shows have always existed the way they have,
you know,
with these seven minutes segments that go to ad break and you know,
one host,
loud boisterous guy talks over everybody.
He shows had been around for so long like that,
that there,
there are comfortable model for us.
Yeah.
And for some people they're not comfortable for me because I tell you,
I've been really trying to rethinking like wearing what can I live in this
world?
But you know,
the U S is,
they're making it very hard for me to want to stay here.
Um,
but you know,
I have children that I have to raise here,
but after that I'm out.
Really,
we are going to go Canada Canada's good fuck.
No,
no disrespect to Canada.
I mean,
uh,
I love it up there.
Canada is really us light and really,
yeah,
I mean Vancouver is a little different,
right?
The rest of cabinet,
is that trying to be like the u s typically when it comes to drugs and all of
these issues?
Yeah.
Vancouver is the most open minded when it comes to drugs.
I mean Vancouver,
I really dig to folks of Van.
Cool.
Don't they have some sort of a heroine program in Vancouver as well?
They do.
It's on the DL.
It's,
and it's for research purposes,
but they certainly have a program where they're giving heroin and it's a
research project that the University of British friend,
uh,
fit British Columbia.
I was there on Friday night.
I did a theater there and you could drive by the theater and get a contact with
your window
open.
Like literally just drive them out.
It's sold marijuana so open,
you know that contact hat thing isn't that kind of,
it's not real.
Right?
It's not real.
I've hotbox people in this very room.
How dare you.
I'm going to change your research.
Fuck some people up in this room.
We are wrecked.
Some people that,
let's do it today.
Let's see if it's a real,
I don't think it's a real,
but you don't think it's real.
We can do an experiment.
Here's another reason why I think it's real.
There's this place in Toronto and uh,
they have,
uh,
I don't want to give them up because I don't think it's legal,
but they do a comedy show there and they have a,
the front is like a bong shop and then the back,
they have a comedy club and they have no ventilation whatsoever.
You walk into the back room,
you are in a fucking cloud of marijuana,
smoke the candles and no longer burning on oxygen.
They're burning on marijuana smoke.
There's no oxygen in the room.
You're breathing pot only and you will get high as fuck.
Cause I have a friend who doesn't even smoke pot and I took him to the show.
He's like straight edge.
He was high as fuck.
He was like,
dude,
I don't even know if I could walk.
And I was like,
exactly.
This is,
this is a reality.
Like you just need to be an extreme situations.
I'll take you to Toronto,
Rochelle,
you,
I bet.
Let's,
everyone will fuck you up.
I guarantee you.
Well,
we need to do is take someone who's totally clean,
like someone who doesn't do any marijuana whatsoever and make them sit in that
audience and watch an hour and a half comedy show and then get up.
That's cool.
That's it.
Do it.
And then we can also test our yard.
We can do all that stuff.
Yeah,
let's do it.
Well,
don't they test positive though?
If you're at a party,
I mean,
can't you,
can't you test positive for some of those more stringent drug tests?
You know,
I,
I know people say that,
you know,
but I,
I haven't seen that,
but I don't know for sure.
I certainly haven't seen it,
but maybe,
maybe it's possible.
Do you know the issue that's going on right now with the UFC and this guy named
Nick Diaz?
No.
This is a huge story in the world of sports because Nick Diaz,
who was one of the most popular fighters in the UFC A and is a,
a very outspoken marijuana enthusiasts.
He's also extremely healthy.
He,
uh,
I think he eats mostly Vegan except I believe he eats some fish.
He a runs triathlons on a regular basis.
He swam back from Alcatraz twice.
He's known for being really one of the most fit guys in the sport,
but he loves marijuana and he smoked it all the time.
Um,
the UFC has instituted in the Nevada state athletic commission has instituted a
new drug policy in regards to marijuana.
Well,
they've lowered the threshold to considerably,
like much,
much lower.
So you literally would have to be high like the day of the fight in order to
test positive.
So he is administered tests from two different organizations.
One of them,
the world antidoping agency water and water is a blood test,
which is much more accurate than what Nevada state athletic commission uses.
Nevada state athletic commission uses a urine test,
the blood test both before and after the fight find him to be under the
threshold.
So he passes.
But Nevada using their urinalysis test,
say that he fails,
they find him $165,000 and then they banned him from the sport for five years.
Yeah.
So that's a huge
rage.
Well,
it should be.
I mean,
really marijuana shouldn't even be on any of the,
even what I know,
what,
uh,
increased their thresholds that that's required to trigger the penalty,
which was a good thing.
Um,
but it shouldn't even be on water is a list because when we think about drugs
and performing enhancing drugs,
clearly people are not using marijuana to enhance performance.
That's not where they're using it for recreational purposes.
And maybe that was the day before or several days before,
uh,
but it certainly has nothing to do with their competition.
And so it should be off of those lists.
And I mean,
this is what people should protest and argue about,
demonstrate about the NFL,
the NBA,
all of these things.
They should remove marijuana from that.
They should also remove cocaine,
cocaine,
it would not be used to enhance performance
inside that in competition,
you don't think it would enhance performance as a stimulant?
Oh,
barely.
I mean,
it's such a short lived thing.
Amphetamines can do a better job with that.
But cocaine would be be barely.
It really would be.
I mean,
but if we start talking about drugs in sports and then we're really being
honest,
um,
we have to think about why are drugs banned from sports in the first place.
I mean,
and so if we start doing that and then we can systematically go through the
illogical sort of reasoning behind these bands,
um,
uh,
people say,
well,
we care about the health of the athletes and drugs.
Okay,
regulate drug use in sports and make sure that they have a physician and so
forth.
But if you really cared about the health of athletes in sports,
you ban boxing,
you been all of these sorts of things,
you ban football.
So that's like,
that's bullshit.
That's not why you go,
that's not why we care about drugs and sport.
Not because of the health of athletes.
That's just not true.
Well,
we say the athletes are role models.
Why should athletes have an additional responsibility more so than anybody else?
That's a very good point.
You know,
so that's crap.
And you just go down the list and think about why we ban these things and it
just doesn't fit.
We banned them because a moralism and war on drugs.
And that's just inappropriate because we're now starting to see that the
rationale on which the war on drugs is built is problematic at best.
What do you think of a situation like say the Lancet Lance Armstrong
situation where he's involved in a sport?
He tests positive for some stuff.
I don't even think he did test positive.
That's right.
I think they weasel their way around the test so well that he never really
tested positive by the,
he ultimately had to admit to using performance enhancing drugs.
They strip him of his tour de France titles.
Then on top of that,
because he was sponsored by the post office,
he,
uh,
gets hit with defrauding the government.
When you defraud the government,
they are allowed to sue you for three times the amount that they gave you.
So if they gave him $30 million,
they're suing him for $90 million or something crazy like that.
And on top of that,
once you strip him,
if you're going to give that title to the next person who didn't test positive
for that,
you got to go down to like 18th place.
Yup.
Which is hilarious.
Yeah.
So like my friend Bill Burr,
hilarious comedian had a great bit that he did about this on the Conan O'brien
show.
He was like,
so basically our steroid it up,
guy beat your steroid it up guy.
I mean there are all steroid it up every,
the whole sport is predicated on it.
I mean if it's what th th th this sport,
and I've even heard it argued by doctors that doing the Tour de France without
the drugs is arguably more dangerous for the athlete's body than doing it with
the drugs.
Well,
the Tour de France has always had drugs in it.
I mean everyone knows this and so this notion that it's going to be clean or it
should be clean,
it's a pipe dream.
It's really ridiculous.
I think that,
you know,
the whole Lens Armstrong issue,
not talking about him specifically,
but we should allow drugs in sports.
That's what,
that's what we should do.
We should just regulate it.
Um,
um,
the,
and be honest and upfront about it.
Is that possible?
Do you think that's possible in this,
in this environment that we're in right now?
Carson's possible,
it was possible right before we got into this environment.
Drugs,
drugs were in sports.
I mean,
we think about the Olympics for most of the Olympics,
people were using performance enhancing drugs.
That's how we got more selective antibiotics,
steroids,
because of the Olympics and East Germans and,
and that whole source of thing.
But actually they were here in America,
but it was competition with the old Soviet Union.
So I think that,
um,
uh,
yeah,
it's possible.
It's possible if we are just,
if we stopped being hypocrites about it and say,
people say,
well,
it gives some people an unfair advantage.
Yeah.
That's a big one.
Now.
That's a joke.
That's really a joke.
I mean,
particularly when I think about every four years when the Olympics come around
and Americans get proud about all the metals we win.
When we fucking win medals from a country like Switzerland that has 7 million
people in New York City has more people in it then Switzerland,
the entire country.
Of course we got to have more metals than Switzerland or some other small
country.
Is that an unfair advantage?
Not Yes,
but hell,
yes it is.
But do we talk about that?
There are some people who have resources and other people don't have resources.
We got to always have does unfair.
So life is unfair.
Well,
the most unfair advantage in the Olympics,
in my opinion,
is when they w NBA players play basketball like Jesus fucking Christ.
I mean,
I know we want to win,
but holy Shit.
You mean you let Michael Jordan or Lebron James or someone along those lines
play in the Olympics against some dude from Czechoslovakia that's kind of fucked
up.
Well,
you know,
they,
their argument was that the other countries were allowing their NBA players to
play fine.
I mean,
but from the outset,
when you have these huge countries like the u s and a competing with these other
smaller countries who have limited resources,
come on.
Are you kidding me?
And we talk about like Ferret,
vantage and unfair that that is also,
there's people that have natural advantages like Lebron James.
Again,
like that guy,
if you look at him,
that is a genetic freak of nature when you have very few people that are ever
going to have a body like his,
right.
I know,
but they're in the NBA.
Right.
But I'm saying even amongst the NBA,
he sort of stands.
He's an outlier obviously.
He's incredibly disciplined.
Obviously he's talented,
obviously is massive work ethic.
No question about it.
Obviously he has basketball intelligence that surpasses nine 9.9999% of the
people in the game.
There's all these other things on top.
But then on top of it,
he has this fucking race car body.
You know,
I mean that like the guy,
you know,
you take a,
someone who's less physically talented there,
they'll never going to,
if they both do the same amount of work,
they both try as hard.
You're never going to be that guy.
But you know,
there are people who have bodies like his and they're not him.
I mean,
you,
you've seen this throughout sports website will have these phenomenal bodies,
but they're not him.
So it's not only their sort of physical makeup,
right?
It's people's drive,
their work ethics.
All of these things I don't think are emphasized enough.
I mean,
uh,
you,
you and I,
the thing about it,
we're talking about Lebron James and not Jack,
Jack,
Jack Brown,
because we don't know him,
but Jack Brown has a hell of a body,
but we don't know him because he doesn't have the ethic,
the work ethic.
He doesn't have the drive.
He doesn't have all of these things.
But you and I can go and look at the NFL roster or some roster and we can see
some guys who are just built and they just look great.
And then we don't know who the hell they are.
Right.
But we're talking about him because this is a selection bias because we see him
and he's doing it.
But I,
I don't dis the whole genetic thing.
I need to see some evidence before I start to talk about genetics.
I,
I don't,
I don't know to what extent that can contribute,
but what I do know is that work ethic and drive and people putting
in the work,
I know that pays off.
I absolutely know that.
It certainly does.
And it,
you,
you need all those things.
You can't just have genetics,
genetics,
just what does that expression to hard work beats talent when talent refuses to
work hard?
Is that it?
Yeah.
And that is,
that is absolutely fine,
but when you got a guy like Lebron James who has talent and hard work,
then you get a superstar and you get that in all sports.
But the argument being that he does have this advantage physically that,
you know,
the average person with an average body just does not have,
but the average person in the NBA does,
they have this body they had,
they look,
they can look like Lebron could,
they know,
could a lot of them.
Oh yeah.
I mean,
there are some guys who are pretty big and uh,
uh,
fast and those sorts of things.
But here's a,
here's a good example.
In the UFC,
I'm in mixed martial arts.
They used to allow testosterone replacement therapy and it was kind of abused.
And the way it was abused is the way the male endocrine system works.
As it's been explained to me.
Obviously I'm not a doctor.
Um,
when you take testosterone,
your body stops producing it.
So what these people would do is they would take it and then uh,
they would get off of it and their body would have very low testosterone.
Then they would get a blood test and the doctor would say,
hey,
you have low testosterone,
you need testosterone replacement therapy.
So we had guys that are in their twenties that were getting testosterone
replacement therapy,
which is kind of crazy.
They would take it and then they would take large amounts of it and recover much
better than other people would.
They would be able to work harder and train harder.
And we had some instances,
and this is one guy named Vitor Belfort,
who was the poster boy for testosterone replacement therapy because his career
was kind of in a lull.
He got on testosterone replacement therapy.
He's a guy who's been fighting in the UFC since 1997.
Okay.
And uh,
he's in his late thirties and then all of a sudden in his late thirties,
he is fucking smashing people and he looks like a God.
I mean,
his body's just chiseled.
He's got super confidence.
He's a super aggressive attacking and he's just highlight reel knockout after
highlight reel knockout in his late thirties.
Then they take away testosterone replacement therapy.
The Nevada State Athletic Commission says,
you know what?
This is just a,
we don't believe in this anymore.
We think this is being abused.
Everyone's going to have to get off of it.
And one of the reasons why they did it is because they tested him out of
competition just randomly.
They grabbed him and he was off the charts like nonhuman levels.
So they,
they make him get off of it.
He then fights for the title after he gets off of it and he looks like a shell
of himself.
His body is like soft.
He's like skin is loose.
Like he,
he just doesn't,
he doesn't have endurance.
Like,
he just,
he got destroyed in the first round by the champion and everybody looks at and
goes,
we'll see.
You know,
this is what happens when you take a guy like that and you'd get them off this
stuff.
But there's a certain amount of people that look at a guy like that and go,
man,
wouldn't you like to see him fight on it?
Wouldn't you?
Wouldn't you like to see what he could do if you had kept him on it?
Cause he seemed like a monster.
Yeah,
I mean,
I know I would.
I like to see,
you know,
because if we got to draw the conclusion that the steroids was the reason that
he was fighting like that.
So now that we did the a portion or the AB portion,
so now we need to go back to a,
put them back on the stove was,
and then,
and then I'll feel more confident that yeah,
it was a steroid.
But the question is though,
is that an unfair advantage for him versus the person he's competing against who
is clean and natural?
His opponent,
Chris Weidman,
who is the champion is a notoriously clean,
he's just hard work,
looks clean,
you know,
it doesn't look like it.
God does any steroids at all.
I just works hard.
He's smart.
He's tough.
Yeah.
So yeah,
so we shouldn't give the champion and option to use steroids.
If he wants to use him,
he can do it.
If he doesn't,
he doesn't have to,
but the other guy,
we should also give them that option into,
let's see what happens.
The problem with that in mixed martial arts as opposed to any other sport is
that giving someone testosterone or a steroid is going to allow them to
administer damage to their opponent that they might not be able to do without
it.
So their opponent is going to suffer because of it.
It's a different thing,
like the ability to deliver a basketball and to net is one thing,
but the ability to kick somebody in the head is a completely different thing.
And the idea being that if you give someone EPO for instance,
which a expands your endurance threshold,
you will be able to throw more strikes.
You'll be able to attack more aggressively without worrying about conserving
your gas tank and the you could damage someone in a way that you would not have
damaged them naturally.
I don't see that as a problem.
I remember when Mike Tyson was knocking people out,
when people walk into the room,
an op in the ring with him,
there was always that potential that you might get damaged in ways my,
that's right.
Yeah.
And so I don't see this as a problem.
We should let it into sports and you know,
this is part of the,
the risk of what you do.
That's,
it's as simple as that for me.
And then we should also monitor to athletes and make sure that they are,
they do have healthy levels and levels that are not going to cause toxicity to
them,
but I don't see that as a problem.
You know,
it's interesting,
conversely,
guys who have gotten off of it,
they can't take punishment.
Like there's a one specific guy and this guy,
if anybody has an argument for taking it,
it's this guy,
his name is big foot Silva and he actually is a giant.
He has gigantism so he has a tumor on his pituitary gland and he was taking um,
external,
what does it x dodginess as he said,
exogenous testosterone.
And if anybody has an excuse for taking
it,
it's this guy.
Well,
when he was on it,
God,
this guy could take a fucking punch to take.
I mean,
he had this war with this guy,
Mark Hunt,
this epic five round fight.
And then when he got off of it,
he gets hit and he just goes down.
Like it's,
it's really shocking the difference in his ability to take punishment while on
it.
And then while,
but see,
you know,
I have to tell you,
I'm a bit outside of my expertise,
so I don't really know these guys,
but,
uh,
I,
you certainly have piqued my interest and I want to know more about it because,
um,
you know,
just to be logically consistent,
I think that these things should be allowed in sport.
And if I'm going to have that position,
I like to know more about the things that you're saying.
Like when he was on it,
he could take a punch.
Then when he got off he couldn't take a punch.
I don't know how many years between that and age,
what role age plays in all of these sorts of things.
But I like to know more.
I'm,
I'm just,
um,
I'm just at a disadvantage because I just don't know.
I don't know enough of the details about it.
Um,
but I would just challenge people to think about,
hey,
what if we allow drugs in sports?
One of the things that it does do that it helps,
it helps
covery and apparently it mitigates the effects of damage.
It can mitigate the effects of a of damage that you take,
not just in,
in training but also in competition.
Yup.
And in that sense it would benefit people.
But I do see the argument and Ronda Rousey's made it pretty eloquently that if
someone is taking a steroid,
if they're,
they're cheating,
quote unquote,
that it's going to allow them to administer damage that they would not have been
allowed to do or wouldn't have been able to do with just hard work.
Well,
I know that's a,
that's a,
um,
that's a conjecture.
But I don't know if that's true.
I don't,
I have no idea if that's true.
I understand.
It's,
it's the most extreme version of sports writing is.
So it's the most extreme consequences for this debate.
Sure.
I,
and I think that it's a perfect place to start because it is that support that
you're going to get into the ring.
You've got to be a man.
You Bet.
I mean,
you better be tough.
A woman or tough,
tough woman,
you better be.
Yeah,
you have to.
You can't be,
you can't be a wimp getting and that ring.
So I think that it's a great place to think about this and,
but the notion that somebody would be able to administer more punishment because
they're on steroids.
I don't know if I accept that.
I don't know if I accept just a guide,
need some evidence to um,
to before I come to that conclusion.
I understand your position.
I'm
pretty sure that's a correct position though.
The,
the,
you would be able to administer more.
Um,
I think if you take very talented athletes that are already,
have all those attributes,
discipline hard work.
Yeah.
And then you add,
you're going to
get a more efficient body.
You're going to get a body that functions more.
Yeah,
yeah,
that's right.
But we're talking about delivering blows.
You can,
you think that people will be able to deliver blows in ways that I do.
And on top of that,
I think also with,
with fighting a big one is confidence.
And there's something about those guys that are choose to the tits.
They,
they're confident as fuck cause they're barely human.
Yeah.
I mean when you hit these super high hyper human levels of testosterone,
you get these incredibly aggressive,
confident men that can do things that they might.
And then subsequently when they get off that stuff,
boy,
their confidence,
it erodes radically Instagram pages start looking like suicidal strippers,
motivational quotes and shit and like,
you know,
they get real weird jealousy,
ultimate experiment that we have to tell people they're on these things and
let's see if they're confident or is increased.
Right.
And we can see whether or not it's the placebo effect.
It's sort of confident thing.
I mean,
but I know that they have real physical effects,
so I'm not denying that at all.
But the competence piece of be interesting to see whether or not somebody will
love still have this confidence if we give them placebo and telling them this is
what the hair,
but isn't it fascinating also that we're,
we're still talking about drugs like that term drugs is just such a weighted and
loaded term.
That fact that that that term could be used for a steroid as well as for aspirin
or coffee.
It's,
it's,
it's really kind of unfortunate that we have this one blanket term that applies
to psychedelics and as well it applies to testosterone and it applies to heroin.
I mean,
there's too many things.
I actually liked that.
Do you?
Yeah.
Why?
What,
what,
why don't you like it?
I mean,
because when we think about one of the things that bothers me about the
psychedelic kind of movement,
and God blessed them,
people who enjoy this thing,
but you know,
people separate their drug use,
like the psychedelic use.
Like I'm using this to go on a higher plane or for some other reason as opposed
to the person on the corner who was getting high.
It's like you can rationalize your drug use however you want,
but you're using drugs and it's all the same thing,
you know?
So it's like,
it's a beautiful thing.
It's like we're all together in this,
I'm not better than you with my drug use and you're not better than me.
What your drug.
Oh,
I see.
I love that.
The lead ism of the psychedelic noise here.
Exactly.
It or other people.
I mean,
this notion like even the marijuana smokers,
when they talk about marijuana and not talk about crack and not talk about
heroin,
what the fuck is that?
I mean,
come on,
you're doing a drug just like I'm doing this drug.
And so it's hypocrisy.
It's the same elite Ism that is pervasive throughout our society.
Well,
I think the idea is that when you're doing marijuana or something like that,
they're,
they're being like a responsible,
they're taking something that makes you more socially aware and casual.
Whereas when you're doing some speed or some math or something like that,
you know,
you're stealing cars and fucking drive it into pedestrians.
That's how people look at it.
Hard,
man.
Because you know,
you know,
I hear these things right?
Like I have done all of these things right.
And it's not like I am stealing cars or doing any of these.
You don't get wacky when you get on the meth.
No.
I mean,
what,
you know,
look at me.
I mean,
my life revolves about around my work and you know,
my idea of a good time is being able to write a new paper to write a book and
but that doesn't,
that doesn't mean that I don't appreciate drugs and drug use.
Right.
And so,
um,
and I think this is the majority of drug users in the world of academia.
Does your stance caused controversy?
Because you know,
you're obviously a very educated guy,
very well respected,
but yet you say this so openly that you enjoy drugs like,
whereas a lot of people would shy away from that even if they do research on the
drugs themselves.
I've had people that,
you know,
even guys that work trying to legalize drugs that are very hesitant to admit
they're falling like Rick Doblin,
I had him on the podcast.
He didn't want to admit that he had taken provigil before the show,
which is he did,
but he was hesitant to it,
you know,
and not just slamming him at all because I love it.
Oh me.
Yeah,
me too.
I was a great guy.
Right,
right,
right buddy.
I found it fascinating that this,
there was this like hesitancy to admit that he took something that is so mild.
Like pro vigil gives you a little bit of energy.
Sure.
It doesn't alter your heart rate.
It certainly doesn't alter critical thinking processes,
but he was hesitant and he's the head of maps.
Yeah.
See,
I'm not to talk about Rick situation specifically,
but just in general,
when people are reluctant to say these things,
that's part of the problem because we need to help people get out of the closet.
There are so many people who go to jail,
who get in trouble,
who lose their job for doing a behavior that well respected people in our
society,
in,
I've been all over the world and I've been hanging out with some of the more,
uh,
some of the movers and shakers in a variety of society and I have seen them get
high and they are responsible people and they are people who I would want my
children to be like in many cases,
some of these folks now,
um,
many of those people are closeted it,
but them being in the closet allows
this hypocrisy to go on,
allows us to go at the poor people for doing a behavior,
engaging in behavior,
in which many of us engage in some very wrong with that.
And that's very,
for me,
very hypocritical.
And I like to look in the mirror as a man,
as an adult,
and to say that I live my life as honestly as I can in that regard.
Um,
and so what kind of man would I be if I wasn't honest about this?
It.
I mean,
I'm the person who has given thousands of doses of these drugs to people and
carefully studied their affects written books on this stuff.
If I can't say this,
why are you here?
Why am I here?
I mean,
what is,
I would be embarrassed as a person and I would deserve to be embarrassed as a
person because I didn't take the opportunity to help my fellow citizens who are
catching hell for doing the same thing that I and others do.
That would be wrong.
Well,
Kudos to you for taking that stance,
but I think that's a brave stance.
It isn't in the world of academia.
Like how was that?
How was that,
uh,
accepted?
Uh,
I don't,
I don't know.
I haven't thought about it.
All I know is that I have to do my job.
So I do my job and you know,
I try and do my job as well or better than my colleagues.
That's all I can do in those spaces.
But,
you know,
I dozer,
dozer and not the spaces that in which I live.
I mean,
I worked there,
but I'm trying to be a citizen of the world.
And so,
um,
that's just a narrow aspect of my life.
That's very admirable and I'm glad you're alive.
Thank you,
man.
Glad there's people like you out there.
It's just so important.
I think.
I really do.
I think,
um,
these conversations where a guy like you who's so educated in the subject can
expand people's minds and say,
say things in such an honest way.
I think it's just,
it's very critical because it's because we are so hesitant to admit these
things.
You know what I mean?
Uh,
I run into situations with parents all the time.
You know,
like I go to school with their kids,
go to school,
and then the Google me,
you'll find out,
uh,
you know,
army,
all the fucking drug talk is the one that freaks them out the most.
Not the fact that I'm involved in cage fighting.
Like that seems fine.
Like they want to get tickets.
You know what the drug stuff is the weird part,
especially the psychedelics ones,
psychedelics are the ones that seem to freak them out.
The mall's more so even than the pot,
like DMT,
like I've had more parents asked me about Dmt,
you know,
with this cute,
curious cross armed.
So what is this DMT stuff?
We'll see.
I have children too,
so you know,
like get stimulus.
So it's a thing.
I'm sure you like me or an odd look and fellow,
you know,
with your crazy dreadlocks,
you long fingernails and liquids.
This motherfucker,
this guy's a doctor.
Yeah.
You just hit it on the head.
But you know,
that's the sort of thing that drives me.
Right.
That's why when people are sleeping,
I'm working.
I mean,
I'm,
I'm working around the clock,
you know?
Uh,
but I pretend that I'm not,
you not pretend like I'm just chilling and you know,
I'm one of the most sort of uptight people you want to meet when it comes to
work,
you know?
Uh,
I am,
uh,
yeah,
I'm a,
I'm a difficult person to work for because you're a workaholic.
Absolutely.
I think your work is very,
very important to you,
obviously.
Yeah,
absolutely.
You know,
it's like if you're going to be in the game,
you gotta be in the game to win it.
Well,
it's also what you're doing is so critical at this juncture,
because I think we're in a transitionary stage in our culture.
I think our culture is opening it's mind.
And I think as we said before,
because of the Internet,
because we're,
we,
we can have conversations like this where no one can step in and stop us.
It's already too late.
Everything you've said,
it's all streamed.
People recorded it.
It's being people who are listening to it right now,
there's no way around that.
People are getting it.
They're playing it in their car.
No one could stop it.
And once that information gets out,
then they'll Google it.
A vast majority of the people that are curious about this,
we'll start looking into some of the things that you've said and go,
wow,
that's true.
Wow,
this is crazy.
And then they'll talk to people at work.
They'll talk to people at the gym,
they'll talk to people that they're friends with,
and then it will expand further and further and further.
So I think what you are doing is critical.
It's critical at this juncture.
So the,
the fact that you approach it like it's so critical is why,
you know,
you're so important.
Well
thank you man.
Because you know,
that's how I try it and see it.
You know,
it's like I think about like,
I don't want to let people down by me not working as hard as that kid
particularly,
uh,
when it's so important as you point out for so many people,
you know,
because young people,
older people,
people always going to get high then always going to get hot.
So one of the things we can do is we can help them do it more safely and more
effectively we can do,
we can actually do that as opposed to saying don't do that.
Come on.
If you're a thinking person,
you want to know why it's more important that kids and people challenge me,
challenge everyone and they,
and when they challenge us,
they might actually go and engage in this behavior.
Okay,
I have my own kids.
So that means my kids hear me talking about this.
So my kids might think,
what drugs aren't that bad?
Cause I heard when my dad said,
so I have to uh,
understand that there's a potential that my kids will use drugs to.
Yeah,
I know that.
But the thing I try to do is make sure they're safe and they know what they're
doing.
And also that they understand their role about educating their friends and
keeping their friends say,
and even educating their teachers.
Like,
I get my kids say,
Dad,
I had the drug talk in class and this is what this person said does.
Teacher said,
or this person said that the majority of people who use marijuana,
um,
go on to use other drugs and become addicted to marijuana,
some other drug.
So my kid,
my young kid has the raised his hand and be like,
um,
Mr x,
it's exactly the opposite of what you just said.
And then the teacher says,
well,
you know,
like what evidence do you have for this sort of thing?
Of course my kids,
they do.
And you just like,
well,
look at the last three presidents of the United States,
you know,
and,
and so he goes on and he educates the teachers and that sort of way.
But you know,
that's,
that's a hard thing for a kid to do.
And,
but he feels compelled to do it because he understands that his,
that's part of his responsibility to,
there was a great,
uh,
well lecture by Terence Mckenna wants,
where he was talking about his kid being in class and Terence Mckenna is sort of
a legendary feature and the figure in the psychedelic community.
And his child was in class and the teacher was telling his child that LSD causes
brain damage.
And he said,
you know,
no,
it doesn't cause brain damage.
And Teachers said,
well,
who told you that?
And he said,
Albert Hoffman.
And like when you've had a conversation with Albert Hoffman and you're dealing
with some fucking high school teacher in podunk,
Colorado,
be interesting if the teacher knew who Albert Hoffman was probably did.
Yeah,
I hope so.
I would hope so.
Yeah.
See this,
the narrative that the brain damage narrative is a big one.
And you know,
like boy,
there's a lot of things that can potentially cause your brain to not function at
its best.
And some abuse of drugs is certainly on that list.
But there's a lot of things that we do on a daily basis that are not good for
you.
Like,
like poor diet,
lack of exercise,
like being stuck in polluted cities like breathing in brake dust and fucking
exhaust fumes all day.
All these things are terrible.
Yeah.
But we,
we really have to challenge the brain damage narrative.
I mean,
one of the things that we do is that we don't challenge it.
so like when we,
one of the things,
when we think about the brain damage narrative,
it has gained more energy in recent years in part because we have this
technology of neural imaging,
brain imaging.
But what in fact,
what has happened with brain imaging is that brain imaging has become a
projection tests basically.
You know what I mean?
When I said projection test,
um,
no I don't,
you know,
ink blot test.
So a or war shop sort of psychological test where you throw up some image and
you ask the person what did they see?
And then you know,
you get to sort of Dale tell you they are interpretation and didn't in
psychologist has his or her subjective of what that means.
That's what brain imaging in drugs,
in the sort of a drug field has become.
It's become a projection test.
So that means that uh,
the sort of what the examiner sees is what um,
uh,
the,
the task or the information becomes.
So it's a subjective sort of view,
a subjective view of what the examiner thinks.
And so you can take brain imaging for example,
you can take the data and give it to two different labs,
just give the data to two different labs and you don't tell them who the
participants are.
I would bet you any amount of money that the two labs would not come up with the
same interpretation.
You know?
So people think of this as like being hard science.
It's there and this is what we,
we see.
And we know it's not that way.
It's a,
it's really,
it's,
there's a lot of subjective subjectivity that goes into these sorts of tests.
And so one of the things we have to do is just push back and ask people when
they talk about these drugs causing brain damage,
where,
what's the evidence that these are the questions that people have to ask.
Please show me the evidence of the brain damage that you're talking about.
Because it's true.
Amphetamines can cause brain damage.
Nicotine is a lot more dangerous than amphetamine,
heroin and all the rest of these things in terms of potency in that sort of
thing.
But we take nicotine and doses that we avoid any sort of damaged at all or most
of the damage associated with,
we take all of these drugs and doses that causes your Foria,
which is way below the doses that causes toxicity.
So when we start talking about brain damage,
humans don't usually take drugs in the doses that will cause brain damage
because if they did,
the drug effects become unpleasant and humans won't take it because it's so
unpleasant.
So the notion that these things cause brain damage,
you need to really ask people to show you the evidence.
I have not seen evidence in humans that all of these recreate any of these
recreational drugs is causing some brain damage.
So when they have those scans and they show the brain and they show the effects,
like when someone's on x amount,
you know,
milligrams of this or of that.
But I always wondered that like what are you seeing when you see like
highlighted portions of the brain?
Like what is that just activity in that area.
So
if we talk him,
most of the studies have been done when people are not on drugs.
I mean we can talk about when people are on drugs would do that.
And so what you do,
you typically do,
you have like a group of methamphetamine users in one group and then you have
people who've never used methamphetamine and other group and you image their
brain.
You might do what this thing we call a pet image.
That was,
that was popular.
What you inject a radioactive compound in somebody's body.
And this compound selectively binds to let's say dopamine cells in the brain and
when it binds to the dopamine cells since his radioactive,
it lights up and it and,
and so you can see how many dopamine sales are in a person's brain or region or
you can get an idea of the dopamine cells and how many are there.
One of the things that has done a sort of a popular way that it's done is that
they say the methamphetamine users have less dopamine receptors then the non
methamphetamine use.
And so that's interpreted as saying methamphetamine caused the methamphetamine
users to lose dopamine cells,
kill sales.
Basically.
Now we don't know what we were,
what was in the brains of the,
of the methamphetamine users before they used methamphetamine.
We only know from this one scan.
That's one problem.
Another problem is,
is that we don't know what the normal range of dopamine receptors or or are,
uh,
an a,
an a person spray.
So if you look at like your brain versus my brain will see differences,
what does that me or if you look at the brains of people who never used drugs or
anything,
you'll see differences.
What it does,
it mean.
And so we have a wide range just as humans,
we have a wide range of dopamine cells in each person's brains versus somebody
else.
So you can't say that methamphetamine caused these people to lose dopamine cells
because we don't know if they lost open me cells in the first place.
And another thing is this,
that you have this tremendous amount of overlap of dopamine cells in this case,
in the methamphetamine users compared to the controls.
So that means that some people in the methamphetamine group has more dopamine
cells than people in the control and vice versa.
So what does it all mean?
It doesn't mean what it typically means is we don't know.
But what we know it doesn't typically mean is that it caused some brain damage.
Because when you look at these people's functioning,
cognitive functioning,
other functioning,
they look just like anybody else who didn't use methamphetamine.
That's fascinating.
Um,
so that's really interesting.
So the only way to tell would be to take someone who is healthy and doesn't have
a history of drug use and monitor them,
get them hooked on methamphetamine,
and then see what's happening to their dopamine receptors.
Then
you certainly that that could be a way of doing that.
But that would be really expensive.
And I don't know if it's just a ethical,
yeah,
I mean we had these natural experiments already,
so we think about amphetamine use became big in the 30s and we have this sort of
history in the military.
We still use amphetamines,
polished shoes,
but a millets are always on that stuff.
Right?
Fly Missions,
right,
to make sure that the sharp,
right.
So you,
you have this history,
so you just look in the population and you say,
all right,
what is a dopamine related illness?
You look at a dopamine related illness.
One of them is Parkinson's disease.
You lose dopamine cells,
you get Parkinson's disease.
Do you have higher rates of Parkinson's disease and methamphetamine users?
And you know,
the bottom line is that you don't generally see this,
you don't see higher rates of method of,
of Parkinson's disease in methamphetamine user.
I mean that's just one thing.
But you can just look to out the society and you can see various illnesses,
particularly neurological illnesses and see do you have a greater rates of this
illness and people who report it,
this type of drug use and you don't really see that.
And so I,
um,
when I hear people talk about the brain damaged thing and particularly when they
show brain imaging,
that's not evidence of brain damage.
You know,
when you have animal studies,
you can give animals in Pheta means for everyday for their life and then you
kill them at,
at some point and then you look at it and fed a dope mean damage for example.
You certainly can see damage when you give amphetamine at doses 30 40 times what
humans take.
Yeah,
you can see some toxicity.
It's clear.
But now when you give to doses that a comparable to what humans take over that
same period of time,
you don't see this really.
Yes.
So the stimulants and the effect of the stimulants don't result in brain damage
unless you're at just ridiculous levels.
Absolutely.
This is the same thing that I worry about with
um,
steroid use.
You know,
this is why I want to make sure that we actually regulate it because we want to
make sure people are not taking doses that are so large that they might actually
be causing some damage and we don't regulate it.
Yeah,
you can,
you run that risk and so regulate it and then you,
and if you really care about people,
that's what you would do.
And then you make sure that you monitor them regularly to make sure that they
don't exceed those levels and you educate.
I'm about the potential consequences.
Well,
a good example of that is probably the bodybuilding community because if anybody
takes steroids at hyper human and on re preposterous levels,
it's bodybuilders.
And yet very few of them wind up dying from it.
There are a few cases of guys that were like really big in the eighties and
nineties that are now dead from heart attack.
But if you ever see what those fucking guys look like,
you realize like these,
these are not people that are taking normal levels.
These are not people that are even taking commensurate levels to their peers.
Like a lot of them are taking just these insane insane and some of them have
come clean about their routines and what they would use.
I mean they were just red lining.
It's,
they were just red lining their system on a regular basis.
We're trying to win and they were trying to,
and that's a sport where you have to take steroids.
I mean,
you're not going
to compete with a Lee Haney or a Dorian Yates.
You're not going to compete with them if you don't take steroids.
It's a sport that is really,
you have to,
it's the only way it works.
Your human body is not supposed to be that big.
Yeah.
Well,
um,
yeah,
Mike had started us that we should make sure we keep them safe by making sure
that they understand what they're doing and how to do it.
Yeah.
But that's,
that is a crazy sport when you think about it.
I mean,
some people don't even consider it a sport,
whatever,
an activity,
whatever you want to call it now,
because it's not like you're doing anything other than standing there looking
big.
It's weird,
right.
Because you're not,
you know what I mean?
It's like you're not trying to run faster.
You just stand there.
Is that a support?
Uh,
you know,
uh,
if they think it is it that competing,
right?
An activity.
It's certainly a legit activity.
And they're competing,
right?
Yes.
I guess,
but they're,
the competition is so subjective.
It's like,
you know,
you look at one guy,
I mean,
I don't get it.
I look at the,
like,
if I look at Mr Olympia and this is like the top five guys,
like they're indistinguishable to me.
They're all just giant,
huge dudes.
I don't know how the fuck does one person when in one person,
not when I don't get it.
Yeah.
But you know,
our ignorance shit,
right.
Prevented him from having to sport,
you know?
No,
I'm not saying prevent them from having a sport.
I'm saying,
is it a sport?
Yeah,
no,
it's an activity.
But that's my thing.
Our ignorance should prevent them from Collins was a sport.
Right?
I mean,
you know,
there are some sports that I just don't get.
I mean,
golf,
it's clearly a sport.
But is it though Mike,
my wrestling coach in high school wouldn't even say baseball is a sport.
He's like,
it's a skill game.
Coach Murphy to skill game.
It's not a sport.
You get tired,
you get tired when you gotta do you gotta push through it.
When you're playing baseball,
you get the fuck out of here.
That's how it sparked and make us run hills.
If we said it was a sport,
okay,
well I'm from animals I feel too.
But you know,
the thing is is that my view on this certainly should not be considered.
You know,
even though that's,
that's because of my own ignorance.
I should not,
I shouldn't have much of a say.
So there,
because of my ignorance,
I understand even though I have my view,
but you know,
my view is less important.
Well in bodybuilding,
if there is consequences to taking the,
the,
the level of steroids that you need to take in order to get that big,
like didn't Arnold have open heart surgery?
I think Arnold had heart surgery.
I'm pretty sure.
So I think for a lot of those guys,
but,
but I don't know has had a fun,
I mean he had,
his life has been,
you know,
I don't know why he had open heart surgery,
so,
but I mean clearly he used arrows.
He said this,
but I don't know if that's the reason.
I mean,
you know,
the number one sort of a reason that people die in the United States is heart
disease and they get that for a variety of reasons.
Many of them I've never taken steroids.
So obesity,
right,
isn't it?
It's obesity,
poor eating habits,
a wide range of things.
Yeah.
Genetics,
lack of exercise.
A lot bad enough alcohol,
no alcohol,
no alcohol.
I mean,
you,
uh,
moderate alcohol use is associated with lower levels of heart disease and stroke
and all the rest of these things.
Why do you think that is?
It just relaxes people.
And it takes a little bit of the edge off and less stress on the body.
Maybe there is a component that has been identified and alcohol that they think
is helpful at getting rid of plaques and that sort of thing.
But I,
it's not definitive.
I don't,
I don't know.
Is that one of those things where you'd have to take a healthy person and expose
them to alcohol?
Does and monitor as well?
Same thing.
I'm fed amine maybe.
Well you know it's like if you do a wide range of different types of studies,
you know,
because there is no perfect study,
but if you have all of these different types of studies and then you have the
evidence coming pointing to the same way,
the same direction,
it increases your confidence that this is real.
And that's Kinda what happened with alcohol.
There have been dozens of large studies with thousands of people that have
looked at folks who don't drink alcohol.
Those people who drink moderate doses and those who drink excessive or larger
doses and the moderate drinkers time at the time,
they are associated with all of these positive outcomes.
And so it's certainly starting to increase my confidence that it's something
real going on where people should drink.
Moderately should drink moderately.
Yeah.
Uh,
wow.
That's controversial,
right?
Is a pretty controversial isn't it?
Isn't it?
I don't go should take a little heroin.
They should drink.
Moderately.
Should do some steroids.
Um,
I'm obviously not really stating your position,
but isn't,
there's a thing in red wine.
Um,
there's an antioxidant called Rivera trawl.
Isn't that something that they've associated with health as well?
They were thinking about it was specific to red wine,
but now they think it's just I'll in general.
Yeah.
In a perfect world,
Dr. Carl Hart,
if you were,
the drugs are first of all,
why the fuck would we have the czar's?
Aren't they like evil?
Isn't there like a fucking dictator when they they are,
yeah.
In a way,
right?
Yeah.
If you know anything about what happens with us drug policy,
you can't help but think that they are evil.
It's kind of ironic then that we call them the drug czar instead of the drug
chairman or the drug,
you know,
overseer or policy coordinator.
You have to understand the first drug czar was William Bennett and I think he,
he,
he tucked that title and that's where is he brand with it?
He's like,
well,
I'm a fucking czar.
I'm going to act like one if you were,
I mean it say if a President Obama or president Trump when he gets into office,
is that scared the shit out of your what?
Not really man.
Cause the same thing I live in this country,
look at all of these people who run this country.
I mean,
uh,
it doesn't care me.
They're all,
they're not that different.
So,
well I think if anybody would be different than might be Trump.
I mean he's a,
he's the only one that's financially independent.
Yup.
And that's probably why he's so well,
and he also has a,
has a personality and the other folks who were for the Republicans
don't have personalities.
That is true.
And this is not an endorsement by no means,
but this is just the state of fact.
He,
he has a personality and personality means a lot in this goofy country.
Yeah.
Um,
if,
anyway,
if someone came along and said,
listen,
Doctor Heart,
you're obviously very educated in this subject,
much more so than the average person.
What do you recommend we do in this country to handle drugs?
Yeah,
so,
um,
the first thing I do,
uh,
you know,
it would be,
you'd be really hard pressed to have me like working government for one.
So I just want to state that because,
um,
the thing that I love about being academia is that I'm a free man.
And then in government,
these people talk about what they can't do because of some of the,
some whatever reason.
I don't understand how you look in the mirror when you say you can't do things.
But if I had some influence on drug policy in this country,
first thing I would do was decriminalized all drugs.
That would be the first thing that would happen immediately.
Then I would change our educational sort of,
uh,
programming in this country,
surrounding drugs,
all of these things that vilified a drug and say that it's the drug that causes
that,
that would be out.
People who are doing this sort of things that the government is paying for,
their money would dry up if they didn't change their,
the way they're educating.
That's,
that's another thing.
Another thing I would do with police forces and that I had control over it.
They would,
when they confiscate drugs,
their domain mission is not to arrest people.
The main mission is to keep people safe.
Whenever they confiscated drugs day would test them for adulterants and see what
else is in that cocaine,
what else is in that heroin?
And they would be published in the local papers.
It will be published in some local sort of form where everyone would know avoid
this type of drug or does packaging because it has,
does,
don't,
don't trust and that's not safe.
Whereas something else,
it doesn't have that adulthood.
And so the people would be informed immediately.
Then another thing I would do,
I would work on um,
uh,
legalizing or regulating drug and all of these drugs.
Figuring out what would be the best regulated market for marijuana.
What would be the best regulated market for cocaine?
What would be the best regulated market for heroin?
Well,
how do we best regulate ecstasy?
How do we do this?
And,
um,
that's,
that's where I would go and we would,
uh,
we would,
we would get rid of the people in jail who are there because of drug violation.
Obama's done a little bit of that.
I just kind of scratched the surface,
getting people out of jail that are in for nonviolent drug offenses.
But it's been,
it was a very small amount of people and it was,
there was a big deal do about it.
And I,
you know,
I couldn't help but be underwhelmed because I think it was only
like 65 people or something like that.
I don't remember what the,
I think the total now has gone up to like 80 south took him.
Jesus Christ.
He's fucking million people in jail.
We have 2.3 million.
Yeah.
But how many of them are in there for now?
No,
you're right.
You're right.
Insane.
It's probably half the population,
right?
Yeah.
No,
I'm with you mid like you,
you've been overwhelmed or underwhelmed.
I have been,
um,
disappointed.
I mean I voted for Obama and,
uh,
I was hoping that we get a lot more relief on this thing.
So I mean,
we,
the crack cocaine was originally punished a hundred times more harshly than
powder cocaine at the federal level.
It's now punished 18 times more harshly than powder cocaine.
That doesn't make any sense.
They're the same drug and that's just racism,
you know,
that's,
or come back to racist targeting economic disparity.
I mean you're,
you're targeting people in poor communities.
Yeah,
yeah.
No,
we doubled our,
um,
uh,
enforcement of drug laws has been racially discriminatory.
That's a fact.
I mean,
but we certainly can come back to the racism piece.
Uh,
but I mean,
so that sort of thing,
we were expecting Obama to,
his administration have pushed for one to one,
equating with crack,
what pattern it didn't happen.
And by the way,
it's 18 to one now.
And then when you look at the arrests of people who are being arrested,
it's still 80% black.
It still does racially discriminatory sort of effect.
So changing that law didn't have any impact on that.
That's one thing.
And then when we think about the people who are being,
the sentences have been commuted,
you know,
he has become the president who has commuted more sentences than any other
president.
I think Johnson was a ahead of him at one point,
but now he's the past Johnson.
But we have to think about when Johnson was president,
we met her that 200,000 people in jail,
you know,
now we got 2.3 million and sell.
So really this is a drop in a bucket and that this is disappointing to me.
I am so,
um,
uh,
discouraged.
Uh,
and um,
uh,
it's heartbreaking actually because we thought we would see this president be
more bold about these things,
raise these issues.
And um,
some of it is re some of these sort of arrests are related to race and race.
Racial discrimination is important.
But one of the things that happens in our country when we start having this
discussion or these discussions about racial discrimination is that we still,
we were in this frame where poor black people,
poor other people,
white people,
all these other people in the country who are catching the same hell are not
working together as a result of keeping it to this conversation,
tie to the ratio of discrimination.
Although racial discrimination is important in,
in a lot of domains,
and that we should not forget that,
but there are people,
there are white poor people catching the same hell for the same or similar
reasons.
The reason might not be conspicuously race,
but it might be for other reasons.
Um,
like I said,
I've been traveling all over the,
all over the world and I went to Belfast,
Northern Ireland,
and you got a lot of fans there.
Like the Catholics,
although they're not really capital,
as many of these people are not really capitalists,
but they're catching hell by,
uh,
for similar reasons.
You know,
they're being dominated by a British sort of a occupation,
if you will.
Um,
and they're,
they have similar problems as poor people have in this country.
And,
and so one of the things I try and I'm struggling with is that I'm trying to get
people to see how poor black people struggles in the u s is connected with poor
white people struggle in Belfast.
It,
their struggles are connected with poor peoples in um,
in Brazil all around the globe.
These people have more things in common.
And then sometimes to conspicuous characteristic of race kind of blinds us from
our connection with other folks.
And,
and,
and so I'm struggling with how to communicate this in a way that everybody can
see,
hey,
we're in the shit together and there are a few elitist sort of people who are
benefiting from us going at each other's throat and not understanding.
And then us also just playing right into it.
One of the things about cocaine and heroin and accuracy as opposed to marijuana
is that marijuana obviously is really easy to make.
I'm going to just put it in the ground.
You water it,
it grows,
harvest it,
it's simple.
It's like you see it as a leaf.
You,
you don't have to worry about there being a bunch of stuff in it.
When you talked about,
uh,
what's the word you use?
Adulterants adulterants someone's taking cocaine and cutting it with something
else.
Yeah.
That,
that becomes you when you'd look at it,
it still looks like white powder.
Yup.
Um,
legalization if we legalized it as opposed to decriminalizing,
if you decriminalizing it,
what'd you do need,
you're not prosecuting people that are using it,
but what do you do with the people that are selling it and how do you move to a,
an ethical,
responsible,
open market for something like this?
Um,
so when you say what do you do with the people who are selling it?
What do you mean?
The people who currently sell node?
No,
no,
no.
We'll be some people that will be,
see if we go to decriminalizing.
Yup.
How,
obviously that means that you're not going to prosecute the people that are
using it,
but how do they get it?
Yeah.
So do we change that?
So decriminalization to think about Portugal and Czech Republic,
um,
you still have the illicit markets in those places.
Right?
And so people have to understand that decriminalization is not to go at the
listed markets.
Uh,
decriminalization,
the major reason that you decriminalize it,
that you don't want to put your citizens in jail and you want to,
uh,
encourage them to get help if they need help.
So it's about the sort of user and that that's kind of what you're doing.
But if you're worried about illicit drug markets and you want to get rid of
illicit drug markets,
then regulation is a way to go.
Legal Law,
legal regulation.
And if you worry about adulterants legal regulation is a way to go because you
get rid of the black market and you get to rid of the potential dangerous
compounds that people cut these drugs with.
That's my major concern.
That's why I kind of pushed for now regulating these markets because I'm more
afraid of the adult trans.
I'm not afraid of heroin.
I know how to keep people safe.
Well,
heroin,
I know how to keep people safe with cocaine,
but I don't know how to keep people safe with some of the cuts because I don't
know what they are.
Right.
And no one knows until you test it.
And it just seems to me that you're,
if,
if we accept the fact that people were doing drugs in this country and we,
we kind of have,
right.
I mean,
it's not like there's ever been a time in our country that people stop doing
drugs.
Even for a month.
There's never been like a month of no one doing drugs in this country.
So the entire top president wouldn't function.
Right.
I mean,
those guys take sleeping pills and stimulants to get going.
they,
they're you,
they have to do,
they're really,
they have to like,
do you think Obama takes sleeping pills?
All right.
Um,
I can't say for sure that he does,
but if you,
if we had a bet,
I will bet you a lot of money daddy does just because he's so tired because he
works so crazy hours.
He would be,
I would say it responsible if he didn't take sleeping pills.
Really?
Of course you need sleep is one of the most important human functions.
And I want my president to be getting sleep.
But when you take sleeping pills doesn't alter your rem sleep and fuck with your
cycles.
Some of them certainly can.
So you try and find ones like opiates are outstanding
for sleep.
You're a big fan of the opiates aren't.
Yeah.
Are you working for the opiate industry?
Are you,
are you involved somehow?
But there are
authors that will work and I'm sure,
yeah,
some good physicians.
I mean you look throughout history,
the presidents have taken stimulants and sedatives as well.
They should because they,
they have to be on these different coasts and the time change and they have to,
it just doesn't make,
I mean,
people who have to be in the public eye,
I assure you they are taking drugs to enhance their human experience and
function.
So,
uh,
to go back to that,
there's never been a time,
it's not like an goal.
There's never been a time where we've gone a month,
a week,
a year,
whatever,
without anyone in this country doing drugs.
So we know that the drugs are always going to exist.
It would seem to me that this country that's obsessed with making money to the
point where we have privatized prisons and we allow people to profit off of
people being in jail,
wouldn't it be a better source of income to instead tax legal sales of drugs to
make everything legal,
tax it,
and then you get the benefit like you got in Colorado.
Colorado is the first state ever to get more taxes from marijuana than they do
from alcohol,
which is incredible.
They made more money this year from out from marijuana than they have from
alcohol and alcohol has been around forever.
If we did that with cocaine and heroin,
with ecstasy and all these other drugs that we know people are already using,
and we also know people are selling illegally and not paying taxes on it.
It's not only people are selling coke and going,
you know what?
I'm a coke dealer.
Bowel responsible Americans.
I like to pay taxes.
I made $100 million here.
Hey,
how'd you make that money?
I'm fucking hustle,
hustle and flow,
you know,
I do.
No one's going to do that.
So we're missing out on all that tax revenue as a country.
I mean,
it's an economically unsound to not legalize it and tax it if you know for a
fact that people are going to do it.
Yeah.
It seems economically irresponsible.
And then the idea of these public or private prisons,
private prisons are a giant issue in this country because they also lobby and
the,
the prison unions,
the prison guard unions and police officer's unions lobby to make sure the drug
laws state in place to make sure that they have work.
It's insidious.
It's creepy and it's scary.
Yeah.
Um,
private prison.
Now the thing is,
is that they're all those things you said,
but understand they only make up 11% of all prison beds in the United States.
Right.
They're trying to,
they are going to Brazil now and they're going to some other places and,
and it's important that we are aware of what you just said,
but we also need to be aware of places like Louisiana.
I think they have the largest number of prisoners in the country.
Um,
they have local sheriffs who kind of operate like private prisons.
So they bid or they get these state prisoners to be housed in their jail and
they receive a certain amount of money for having those,
those prisoners in their local jails.
So this is a way for the local sheriffs to generate income revenue by taking the
prisoners from state prisoners into their local Gerald jails.
And so this technically is not private prison,
but this is certainly unscrupulous and people should be aware of this going on
throughout the country as well.
So private prisons are concerned,
but also these local jails and local sheriffs,
they're doing similar things.
But legalizing drugs though would be financially a huge boon to our economy.
Yeah,
I think so.
Um,
um,
yeah,
I think so,
but uh,
people will,
um,
people,
I don't know if that argument alone is,
is going to be as,
can it be compelling?
I mean,
I,
I certainly think it's an important argument.
Sure.
No,
not alone,
but it,
it's something that should be considered,
especially in the wake of what's going on in college,
right?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
And there are people who are saying in terms of Colorado,
they're saying that,
yeah,
Colorado is generating all of this tax revenue,
but they're having to pay out a lot of it too because they have to enforce this
new law.
And so people are kind of distorting this sort of story.
But I think over time,
Colorado and other places,
it is going to show that this is a huge benefit and the benefits far outweigh
the risks I think.
And similar to what's going on in Portugal where you see the decrease in violent
crime,
the decrease in addiction,
the decrease in all sorts of different problems that are associated decrease in
revenues to their prisons and all of those things.
Yeah.
All the negative aspects of that we associate with drugs.
A lot of it is negative aspects of crime.
Yeah.
See the thing about Portugal too,
you have to understand,
um,
in places like Portugal,
Switzerland knows kind of places where they kind of take care of their people.
They are more of a homogenous society than we are.
And when,
when you have a place like the United States where we're not as much as like La,
you guys have every nationality,
ethnic group raised their all here,
not homogenous at all.
And so what are the things that the drug laws have has done?
It has allowed us to separate out those people we don't like and go after them.
So if we decriminalize it makes it more difficult.
So you taking away that tool,
whereas Portugal to Swiss and those folks,
there's such a marginal societies,
they kind of care about the people in their society because the people who are
empower,
um,
they see that many of the people who might be,
uh,
subjected to these laws,
they look like them.
They are then,
um,
and our society,
since it's not as homogeneous,
it's easy for us to think about these drug laws being used to go out to those
people who don't share our values.
That's,
that's what we say.
But they really don't look like us and they're really not us.
So this can't really happen because we know that there are a number of people
who,
who look like folks who are in Washington and they're using drugs,
they're using a lot of drugs,
but they're not subjected to drug policy.
I see what you're saying.
And so it's like we have to be honest about why we have these policies in place
in the first place.
They allow us to go out to the people we don't like without explicitly saying
so.
So I think overall,
I guess an overview we're,
we're,
we're looking at is we have a society that has a lot of ignorance when it comes
to both the prevalence of drugs,
the use of drugs and the effect of drugs.
And that ignorance is part of the problem and it's shaped not just public
opinion,
but also shape policy shaped how politicians address these issues.
Like,
like a guy like Chris Christie that is allowed to say ignorant stuff.
The reason why he's not booed off stage and he does it is for a lot of the
people in the audience,
they don't know that what he's saying is unbelievably ignorant.
Yeah.
And he kind of provides the cover for them,
you know,
um,
they kind of support these things because they're not happening to them.
And it's those other people who don't share their values is what they say,
but they really don't look like them.
They don't,
they don't dress like them.
They don't go to the same schools,
they don't do any of these things.
So Christie,
when he says that he's saying this because he's representing a,
what many Americans think and he's providing cover for that bigoted ignorance or
that,
uh,
uninformed perspective.
So what you're doing now with this touring all around the world and are you
speaking and all these places?
Like what,
how do,
what are you doing?
Yeah.
You know,
I,
uh,
I spoke at the World Health Organization as past summer,
um,
universities in Belfast and London.
Uh,
Geneva of course,
uh,
Brazil.
It was just down there speaking.
Uh,
I'll be in Canada next month.
Um,
so just doing all of these,
these talks,
I'm trying to have these kinds of conversations,
trying to inform people,
trying to let people know that they've been hoodwinked all around the world.
And they've been hoodwinked,
um,
particularly countries that follow the US drug policy and trying to expose why
the countries are following this policy that it has had.
It's having detrimental impact on their citizens.
How was this received?
Is it re universally received or is there,
there's different places that are more open to it?
Yeah.
You know,
in Brazil for example,
uh,
they have followed the u s wholeheartedly and Brazil has 50% of their population
is black,
right?
50%.
They have like the greatest African population outside of Africa.
Uh,
they,
uh,
and Mo and prisons,
they're jails filled Phil black people.
And,
uh,
the poor people in the country up and their drug policy is being used as a tool
to further marginalize this group basically.
And so when I go down there and speak and abroad,
dare by their government,
oftentimes it's well received even from the ruling class and the government.
And so it's a conundrum to me,
quite frankly,
that I'm so well received there by the ruling class.
Um,
but,
uh,
there are some people who,
who are,
uh,
very interested in changing policy Geneva and those places.
What I'm saying to them,
those folks there and they're like,
no shit.
We know that,
you know,
and they,
they are Derek.
Drug policy is reflected or it's more a rational go to France.
They're equally as ignorant as we are,
and they use their apologetic policy just like we do.
And they're equally Agner arrogant as we are.
Um,
Belfast,
uh,
they are,
um,
they're trying,
I mean,
they are there.
Derek Catholic population,
you know,
they're on the siege basically.
Um,
um,
Vancouver,
they feel the message of course,
um,
uh,
Norway,
all of these people,
they are responding because they know this is not,
I'm not,
um,
I wish I was brilliant and bright and all those things.
I'm not,
you know,
this is not anything that's earth shattering date.
These people know many of the people around the world,
Columbia and was in Columbia.
Um,
those people,
they're politicians.
They know,
but they're getting a lot of money from the US to continue this sort of war on
drugs.
Mexico,
they know,
but they're getting a lot of money from the u s to continue this war on drugs.
Hasn't,
Mexico decriminalized a lot of things.
They decriminalized everything,
but nobody talks about it because,
uh,
as I pointed out earlier in Portugal,
a person is allowed to have a 10 day supply of drugs before that that triggers
some sort of criminal prosecution.
So you can have a 10 day supply,
a methamphetamine,
heroin,
whatever.
In Mexico you get,
you trigger a criminal offense when you have just a small amount of something.
So it's like,
it's really not decriminalization,
uh,
you know,
it's just,
they lowered the threshold that,
that trigger a criminal process of prosecution.
And so,
uh,
it's,
it doesn't really play out in the spirit of decriminalization.
So they're still,
they probably did it to appeal to the United States laws or to abide by what the
United States is looking for them to do.
Yeah.
I don't know exactly why they did it,
but I know they're continuing their war on drugs.
Um,
in part because of us,
um,
which is a war on drugs is really a war on people and particularly a war on poor
people as we know.
And I'm against wars,
you know,
and I'm an ex military person now.
People want to see you talk and are you still traveling?
Yeah.
We're gonna find out about you.
My website,
Dr Carl hart.com.
And when's the new book coming out?
New Book won't be out until that,
that a presidential election.
Okay.
All right,
man.
Well thank you very much.
Uh,
you're always awesome.
Really appreciate you coming on here,
man.
I,
I really dig what you do and thank you for having me.
Thank you,
sir.
I appreciate that very much.
And follow him on Twitter.
Dr. Carl Hart on Twitter.
Dr Karl,
is it Dr. Carl Hart Dot Com is your website?
Yeah.
Okay.
Thank you brother.
Appreciate it,
man.
Thank you.
Can I everybody
oof.